THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. WE HAVE. WE
ARE LACKING TWO MEMBERS FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. I SAW SEVERAL MEMBERS
JUST MOMENTS AGO AND ASKED THEM
TO JOIN US. WE'RE LACKING. JUST.
WE GOT A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR ASHBY. OH DON'T WAIT A
MINUTE. I OBVIOUSLY SCARED
SENATOR ASHBY. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE HOLDING THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IN ROOM 112 OF THE
CAPITOL. ASK ALL MEMBERS WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT THEMSELVES IN ROOM 112
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AT THIS TIME, MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. I'M BURKE HERE. UMBERG
HERE. WILK ALLEN. ASHBY. ASHBY.
HERE. CABALLERO. DURAZO DURAZO.
HERE. LAIRD. NILO HERE. NILO.
HERE. ROTH STERN. STERN. HERE.
WAHAB. WAHAB, HERE. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
ALRIGHTY, WE HAVE ONE BILL TO
PRESENT TODAY. THAT'S AB 1755 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. WE'RE
GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCEDURE AS WE FOLLOWED ALL
YEAR, WHICH MEANS THAT WE'LL
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK, AND
EACH PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OTHER SUPPORTERS ARE
WELCOME TO STATE THEIR NAME,
THEIR AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION BY APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. WE'LL FIRST TAKE THE
SUPPORT AND THEN WE'LL TAKE THE
OPPOSITION. AFTER WE HEAR FROM
THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION,
WE'LL COME BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS, WE CAN
READ. SO IF YOU HAVE OTHER
INFORMATION YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMUNICATE TO US, YOU CAN DO SO
BY SUBMITTING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE, BY GOING ONLINE AND
LOOKING AT THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE, AND PROVIDE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS AS TO HOW YOU CAN
SUBMIT WRITTEN MATERIAL. ALL
RIGHT. WITH THAT, LET'S BEGIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. AB 1755 IS A JOINT CALL
BILL TO ADDRESS THE RAPIDLY
GROWING BACKLOG OF CIVIL CASES
INVOLVING DISPUTES OVER
CALIFORNIA'S LEMON LAWS SINCE
THE END OF THE PANDEMIC ERA,
RESTRICTIONS ON COURT HEARINGS,
THE NUMBER OF LEMON LAW RELATED
LAWSUITS FILED IN CALIFORNIA HAS
DOUBLED. IN FACT, JUDGES REPORT
THAT IN LA COUNTY ALONE, LEMON
LAW CASES NOW REPRESENT 10% OF
ALL CIVIL FILINGS IN THE COUNTY.
THE CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
DISCOVERY DISPUTES, PROTRACTED
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS, AND
DISAGREEMENTS REGARDING FEES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYING MANY
CALIFORNIANS ABILITY TO REPLACE
A DEFECTIVE CAR WITH A SAFE AND
RELIABLE FORM OF TRANSPORTATION.
AB 1755 REPRESENTS A COMPROMISE
BETWEEN THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS AND SOME AUTO
MANUFACTURERS, MOST NOTABLY
GENERAL MOTORS. THE COMPROMISE
HAS THREE PRIMARY COMPONENTS.
FIRST, THE BILL ADOPTS NEW PRE
LITIGATION PROCEDURES DESIGNED
TO KEEP DISPUTES FROM EVER GOING
TO COURT. CONSUMERS MUST NOW
INFORM MANUFACTURERS IN WRITING
IF THEY WANT A LEMON VEHICLE
BOUGHT BACK OR REPLACED.
OTHERWISE THEY FORGO THE ABILITY
TO SEEK CIVIL PENALTIES.
MANUFACTURERS RECEIVING THIS
NOTICE MUST AGREE TO REPLACE THE
VEHICLE WITHIN 30 DAYS, OR ELSE
THE CONSUMER MAY GO TO COURT. IF
THE PARTIES REACH AN AGREEMENT,
THE MANUFACTURER MUST COMPLETE
THE REPURCHASE OR REPLACEMENT OF
THE VEHICLE WITHIN 60 DAYS.
SECOND, IN THE EVENT A LAWSUIT
IS FILED, THE BILL ADOPTS
STREAMLINED EARLY DISCOVERY AND
MEDIATION. PARTIES MUST PROVIDE
A MANDATORY SET OF DOCUMENTS AND
DISCOVERY WITHIN 60 DAYS OF THE
DEFENDANT RESPONDING TO THE
LAWSUIT. THE PLAINTIFF AND
DEFENDANT MUST SUBMIT TO A
DEPOSITION WITHIN 120 DAYS OF
THE DEFENDANT'S RESPONSE. BOTH
PARTIES MUST ATTEND MEDIATION
WITHIN 150 DAYS. FINALLY, BOTH
SIDES MUST HAVE A PERSON CAPABLE
OF SETTLING PRESENT AT THE
MEDIATION. THE PARTIES MAY SEEK
EXTENDED DISCOVERY AND
LITIGATION ONLY IF THE EARLY
DISCOVERY AND MEDIATION FAIL. I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED THIS MORNING CLARIFY
THAT ANY RESPONSE FROM A
DEFENDANT TRIGGERS THE DISCOVERY
TIMELINES, NOT JUST AN ANSWER,
THUS ELIMINATING ANY CHANCE FOR
GAME PLAYING BY LITIGANTS. THE
BILL ALSO ENHANCES CERTAINTY AND
LITIGATION. TIMELINES AND
SETTLEMENTS. THE BILL NARROWS
THE TIMELINE FOR FILING LEMON
LAW CASES TO ONE YEAR AFTER THE
FINAL WARRANTY EXPIRES, OR SIX
YEARS TOTAL FROM DELIVERY OF A
VEHICLE. THIS IS STILL MORE
GENEROUS THAN OTHER STATES. 47
STATES LIMIT THEIR LEMON LAW
REMEDIES TO THE YEAR OR TWO
AFTER A CAR IS PURCHASED, OR 18
TO 24,000 MILES. FINALLY THE
BILL EXPEDITES SETTLEMENT
COMPLETION BY PROVIDING ONE
STANDARD STATUTORY FORM FOR
REPURCHASE, REPLACEMENT
AGREEMENTS, THUS ELIMINATING THE
NEED FOR NEGOTIATIONS REQUIRING
A SETTLEMENT TO BE COMPLETED IN
A TIMELY MANNER, OR ELSE BOTH
SIDES FACE POSSIBLE CIVIL
PENALTIES AND SANCTIONS, AND
REQUIRING THE MANUFACTURER TO
PROVIDE THE CONSUMER A CHECK OR
A NEW VEHICLE. AT THE TIME, THE
LEMON IS TURNED IN. THESE
CONSUMER FRIENDLY CHANGES SEEK
TO PROMOTE TIMELY RESOLUTION OF
CASES OUTSIDE THE COURT WHEN
POSSIBLE. LASTLY, LET ME BRIEFLY
ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION
AND NOTE WHAT THE BILL DOES NOT
DO. THE BILL DOES NOT ALTER ANY
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS UNDER
EXISTING LEMON LAWS. MUCH LIKE
TODAY, MANUFACTURERS ARE
OBLIGATED TO CONFORM VEHICLES TO
THEIR WARRANTY. SIMILARLY, THIS
BILL DOES NOT CANCEL ANY
WARRANTY IF A WARRANTY ISSUE
ARISES AT ANY TIME DURING A
WARRANTY'S EXISTENCE. THE
EXISTING LAW RELATED TO WARRANTY
CONTRACTS STILL APPLIES THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT IMPACT THE
WARRANTY CLAIMS. THIS BILL DOES
NOT SHIFT ANY BURDENS ON
PLAINTIFFS. IT MERELY CODIFIES
EXISTING PRACTICES AND ON THE
GROUND REALITIES RELATED TO
NOTIFYING MANUFACTURERS ABOUT A
CAR BEING A LEMON, AND ONLY
APPLIES THESE TO ACTIONS SEEKING
CIVIL PENALTIES. THIS BILL DOES
NOT ALTER A MANUFACTURER'S
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY TO REPLACE
LEMONS ONCE A VEHICLE HITS THE
REQUISITE NUMBER OF REPAIRS. IT
SHOULD BE REPLACED OR
REPURCHASED, AND DAMAGES CAN
BEGIN ACCRUING AT THAT TIME.
THIS BILL DOES NOT DELAY
LITIGATION OR PERMIT NEFARIOUS
LITIGATION TACTICS. RATHER, THIS
BILL STREAMLINES DISCOVERY AND
ADOPTS SANCTIONS FOR BAD
BEHAVIOR. THIS BILL DOES NOT
GRANT NEW ATTORNEYS FEES. GIVEN
THAT THE ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE ATTACHES BEFORE A
LAWSUIT IS FILED, FEES FOR PRE
LITIGATION ACTIVITIES ARE
TYPICALLY COVERED UNDER EXISTING
LAW. THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
THAT. FINALLY, THIS BILL DOES
NOT AUTHORIZE BULK SETTLEMENTS
MUCH LIKE EXISTING LAW. THIS
BILL DEALS WITH ONE PLAINTIFF
AND ONE DEFENDANT AT A TIME, AND
IN NO WAY AUTHORIZES NEW CLASS
ACTIONS OR THE GROUPING OF
DISTINCT CLAIMS FROM DISTINCT
PARTIES. THIS BILL SIMPLY SEEKS
TO PROVIDE A PROCESS FOR THE
EXPEDITIOUS RESOLUTION OF LEMON
LAW CLAIMS BY INCENTIVIZING ALL
PARTIES TO REACH EARLY AND
AMICABLE OUTCOMES. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE GREG
RIZZO, ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA, AND
MIKE BOEHLERT ON BEHALF OF
GENERAL MOTORS. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MR. RIZZO. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS. MY
NAME IS GREG RIZZO. I AM THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEY OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT AND ONE OF THE CHIEF
NEGOTIATORS ON AB 1755. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF YOU TO
KNOW THAT AB 1755 WAS NEGOTIATED
WITH LEMON LAWYERS FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE FENCE WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WEREN'T
GOING TO AFFECT LEMON LAWS, BUT
WE WERE GOING TO FIX THE COURT
CONGESTION PROBLEM. SITTING ON A
BUNCH OF BOARDS WITH JUDGES AND
LAWYERS, I CAN TELL YOU THAT ALL
OF US KNOW THAT LEMON LAW
DISCOVERY FILINGS ARE KILLING
THE CONSUMER'S RIGHTS TO GET
TRIAL DATES AND TO GET JUSTICE.
SINCE 2022, LEMON LAW FILINGS
HAVE DOUBLED FROM 15,000 PER
YEAR TO 30 SINCE 2014. LEMON LAW
FILINGS HAVE INCREASED OVER
$25,000.20 5000 CASES A YEAR.
THAT'S 30,000 CASES THAT WILL BE
FILED THIS YEAR. FURTHER
CONGESTED COURTS THAT ARE
ALREADY BACKLOGGED FROM THE 2020
COVID PANDEMIC. AS I SAID
BEFORE, AB 1755 FIXES THE COURTS
CONGESTION PROBLEMS BY CHANGING
THE COURT PROCESSES WITHOUT
AFFECTING THE CONSUMERS RIGHTS.
THE AFFIRMATIVE DUTIES REMAIN.
THE WARRANTY RIGHTS REMAIN. AB
1755 IMPOSES STRICT DEADLINES ON
PRE FILING PROCEDURES TO HELP
IDENTIFY AND GET. LEMON LAW CARS
GET LEMON CARS OFF THE ROAD
WITHIN 60 DAYS OF A COMPLAINT.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT OFF THE ROAD
ON THE 60TH DAY, THERE IS A $50
PER DAY PENALTY AGAINST THE
MANUFACTURER, A STRICT SANCTION
THAT EXISTS NOWHERE ELSE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AB
1755. ALSO, TO FIX THE COURT
CONGESTION IMPOSED STRICT
DEADLINES ON DISCOVERY
PROCEDURES, PROCEDURES THAT BOTH
SIDES WERE HAVING THINGS TO GET
DONE. THEY WILL NOW GET DONE IN
A TIMELY FASHION, AND IF THEY
DON'T, THERE ARE EXTREMELY
STRICT PENALTIES ON THE
MANUFACTURER, INCLUDING THEY
WOULD HAVE TO PAY A HIGHER FINE
THAN THE CONSUMER. RECOGNIZING
THE DISPARITY IN THE FINANCES
BETWEEN A CONSUMER AND $1
BILLION COMPANY. AND THERE ARE
TRIAL EVIDENCE, SANCTIONS THAT
EXIST NOWHERE ELSE IN THE UNITED
STATES WHERE THEY LOSE DEFENSES
IF THEY DO NOT ACTUALLY COMPLY.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES, BECAUSE
IT'S GOOD FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
GET THESE CARS OFF THE ROAD AND
TO FIX THE COURTS SO OTHERS CAN
GET TRIAL DATES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. BLOW.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MIKE BALLARD, ON BEHALF
OF GENERAL MOTORS. JUST TO
CIRCLE BACK ON A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT WERE SAID CASES HAVE
GONE UP SEVEN FOLD SINCE 2015. I
HAD TO LOOK UP THE WORD
SEPTUPLET IN NINE YEARS. PEOPLE
ARE SOMETIMES, IN THESE CASES, 2
TO 3 YEARS. THERE IS NO WAY THAT
A CONSUMER SHOULD BE FORCED TO
WAIT 2 TO 3 YEARS FOR RELIEF ON
A LEMON LAW CLAIM. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO GET TO WORK
AND GET TO SCHOOL. LET'S TALK
ABOUT OR GET THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL. LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
THE BILL IS. IT'S PROCEDURAL, A
VERY SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF THESE
CASES WILL BE RESOLVED BEFORE
LITIGATION. WHAT THE BILL DOES
IS IT ESTABLISHES A REQUIREMENT
CONSISTENT WITH 49 OTHER STATES
THAT MANUFACTURERS BE GIVEN A
SIMPLE DEMAND TO DO A REPURCHASE
OR REPLACEMENT. THAT GOES TO
THIS QUESTION OF WILLFULNESS. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE MANUFACTURER,
IN ORDER TO BE FOUND WILLFUL AND
SUBJECT TO CIVIL PENALTIES,
OUGHT TO GET NOTICE. A SIMPLE
EMAILED NOTICE FROM THE CONSUMER
THAT THEY WANT A BUYBACK. THE
BILL REFORMS DISCOVERY. THIS IS
A KEY POINT. WE HAVE HEARD CASES
WHERE COURTS HAVE SEEN LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF MOTIONS TO COMPEL
DISCOVERY IN A SINGLE CASE. THIS
IS AN AUTOMOBILE CLAIM. THIS IS
NOT IP, THIS IS NOT A
COMPLICATED PRODUCTS LIABILITY
ACTION. THERE IS NO REASON WHY
THERE SHOULD BE HUNDREDS OF
DISCOVERY REQUESTS. THE BILL
LAYS OUT EXACTLY WHAT SORTS OF
DOCUMENTS SHOULD BE EXCHANGED
EARLY IN THE CASE, AND WE THINK
THAT WILL LEAD TO RESOLUTION.
ALSO SHORTENED DEPOSITIONS AND
MANDATORY MEDIATION. FINALLY, IT
HAS A STANDARD RELEASE.
SOMETIMES LAWYERS GO BACK AND
FORTH MONTHS ABOUT WHAT THE
CONSUMER SHOULD HAVE TO RELEASE
IN ORDER TO END THE CASE. AND
THIS HAS A STANDARD RELEASE IN
THE STATUTE. IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THE VERY CONTENTIOUS ISSUE OF
OFFSETS AND DAMAGES VERY
QUICKLY. WHAT THE BILL DOESN'T
DO, IT DOESN'T AMEND SONG
BEVERLY IN ANY WAY. AND LET'S BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT. THAT WAS
SOMETHING GM WOULD HAVE LIKED.
THE PLAINTIFFS BAR COULDN'T GO
THERE. THIS DOES NOT AMEND SONG
BEVERLY, NOR DOES IT AFFECT THE
HOLDING IN THE SEMINAL CASE OF
CROTON VERSUS PORSCHE. IT
DOESN'T AFFECT OTHER REMEDIES.
BOTH EXPRESS WARRANTIES IMPLIED
WARRANTIES, CONSUMER LEGAL
REMEDIES ACT, AND PRODUCTS
LIABILITY. FINALLY, IT'S FASTER,
MORE EFFICIENT, AND WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS FOR
THEIR NEGOTIATION FOR MONTHS IN
GOOD FAITH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. BLOAT. AND I NOTE THAT
THE TWO WITNESSES WENT ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES AND 15 SECONDS. AND
SO FOR THE OPPOSITION, I WILL
ACCORD THEM THE SAME AMOUNT OF
TIME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. NOT
YET. ON THE OPPOSITION. LET'S
TAKE SUPPORT. IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1755, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
FORD MOTOR COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR AND
SENATORS CLIFF COSTA, TODAY, ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF CLIENTS,
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT,
THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL,
THE CIVIL DEFENSE LAWYERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND THE RV
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS CORY
SALZILLO WITH S¼ ON BEHALF OF
STELLANTIS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. I THINK I'M GOING TO
ASK THE WITNESSES WHO WERE HERE
IN SUPPORT TO VACATE FOR THE
MOMENT. YOU MAY NEED TO COME
BACK HERE IN A LITTLE WHILE AND
ASK THE OPPOSITION TO PLEASE
APPROACH. AND SO YOU CAN, WHO
WOULD WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST? ALL RIGHT. AS I AS I
MENTIONED, YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
TIME, SO GO AHEAD. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. I'M ROSEMARY SHAHAN,
PRESIDENT OF CONSUMERS FOR AUTO
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY, AND I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF CARS.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN DESIGNATED AS
A POINT OF CONTACT FOR A LARGE
COALITION OF THE NATION'S
LEADING PRO CONSUMER, AUTO
SAFETY AND INJURY PREVENTION
ORGANIZATIONS. AS WELL AS MANY
LEADING CALIFORNIA BASED
CONSUMER AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AS OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
AND FIRST, I'D LIKE TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO COUNSEL FOR SUCH A
FAIR AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS,
ESPECIALLY AT THE END OF
SESSION, AND SINCE 1979, I'VE
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS TO PROTECT NEW
AND USED CAR OWNERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES. CARS
SUCCESSFULLY SPEARHEADED
ENACTMENT OF NUMEROUS LAWS OVER
THE YEARS, INCLUDING THE 1982
TANNER ACT THAT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW BY JERRY BROWN, OTHER LAWS
THAT WERE SIGNED BY GOVERNORS
WILSON AND SCHWARZENEGGER AND,
TO EXPAND THE LAW TO COVER SMALL
BUSINESSES, WHICH MOST STATES
DON'T COVER. AND OUR MILITARY
FAMILIES. AND THAT BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY IN BOTH HOUSES,
EXPANDING PROTECTIONS FOR
MILITARY, NO MATTER WHERE THEY
BUY THEIR CARS AND TIGHTENING
PROTECTIONS AGAINST LEMONS WITH
LIFE THREATENING SAFETY DEFECTS.
SO INSTEAD OF HAVING TO TAKE
YOUR CAR BACK FOUR TIMES BEFORE,
IT WAS PRESUMED TO BE A LEMON
AND YOU'RE ENTITLED TO A REFUND,
YOU HAD THE BENEFIT OF THE
PRESUMPTION IN THE TANNER ACT TO
BRAKE FAILURES. YOU DON'T HAVE
TO KEEP RISKING YOUR LIFE.
YOU'RE ENTITLED TO A REFUND.
CARS AND OUR COALITION PARTNERS
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WOULD DRASTICALLY WEAKEN
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA'S NEW
AND USED CAR BUYERS. BRIEFLY,
HERE ARE JUST FOUR OF THE WAYS
THE BILL WOULD WEAKEN
CALIFORNIA'S RECIPE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE LEMONADE FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE 1970, WHEN
GOVERNOR REAGAN SIGNED THE
GRANDDADDY OF THE LEMON LAW,
KNOWN AS THE THÀNH BEVERLY
CONSUMER WARRANTY ACT. IT WOULD
DENY FULL LEMON LAW PROTECTIONS
FOR VEHICLE OWNERS WHO HAVE
WARRANTIES THAT LAST BEYOND SIX
YEARS. AFTER THE CAR IS SOLD,
INCLUDING EMISSIONS, WARRANTIES
AND WARRANTIES FOR EV BATTERIES,
WHICH ARE GENERALLY LONGER. SOME
OF THEM ARE MANDATED AND UNDER
THE ORIGINAL SONG, BEVERLY
CONSUMER WARRANTY ACT, NO MATTER
HOW LONG THE WARRANTY IS, THE
MANUFACTURER IS SUPPOSED TO
HONOR IT, AND IF THEY DON'T, IF
THEY WILLFULLY VIOLATE THEIR
WARRANTY, THEY'RE SUBJECT TO UP
TO DOUBLE ITS DISCRETIONARY.
THE, AMOUNT OF YOUR DAMAGES. SO
THAT ACTUALLY GIVES THEM AN
INCENTIVE TO FIX THE CAR. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAN, THAT'S TWO
MINUTES AND 54 SECONDS, SO.
OKAY, WRAP IT UP. THAT'D BE
GREAT. OKAY, SIR, SENATOR, IT
WOULD LIMIT THE TIME FOR
BRINGING A LEMON LAWSUIT TO JUST
ONE YEAR AFTER THE WARRANTY
EXPIRES, HARMING CONSUMERS WHOSE
VEHICLES HAVE LATENT DEFECTS.
NOW, IT'S FOUR YEARS FROM
WHENEVER THE CLAIM ARISES. IT
WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT LEMON
OWNERS WITH NEGATIVE EQUITY
WOULD RECEIVE AS A REFUND BY AN
AVERAGE OF ABOUT $6,000. AND
WORST OF ALL, IT WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER FOR MOST PEOPLE WHO NEVER
EVEN TALKED TO A LEMON LAW
ATTORNEY TO GET THEIR CARS FIXED
UNDER WARRANTY BY SHIFTING THE
BURDEN FOR FLAGGING WHEN A
VEHICLE'S A LEMON FROM THE
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE THAT
OBLIGATION NOW. SO THANK YOU. SO
YOU URGE A NO VOTE. WE STRONGLY
URGE A NO VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN. VICE
CHAIRMAN WILK AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
JOHNSON, AND I'M SENIOR COUNSEL
AT VOLKSWAGEN GROUP OF AMERICA,
WHERE I'VE HANDLED LEMON LAW
MATTERS FOR OVER EIGHT YEARS. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON ASSEMBLY
BILL 1755. I COME BEFORE YOU ON
BEHALF OF 14 AUTO MAKERS. THAT'S
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THERE CAN BE NO DOUBT THAT
UPDATING THE SONG BEVERLY ACT IS
CRUCIAL TO ENSURING FAIR DISPUTE
RESOLUTION, SAFEGUARDING
CONSUMERS AND PROMOTING PUBLIC
SAFETY. UNFORTUNATELY THIS HASTY
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS, WHICH
STEMMED FROM A LAST MINUTE DEAL
BETWEEN ONE COMPANY AND ONE
PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY
ORGANIZATION, WILL HARM THE VERY
CONSUMERS IT INTENDS TO PROTECT.
THIS FLAWED PROCESS HAS LED TO A
FLAWED PROPOSAL THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY DO MORE HARM. DESPITE
ITS GOOD INTENTIONS, THIS BILL
MISSES THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL AND COMMON SENSE
REFORMS THAT ADDRESSES THE REAL
PROBLEM, THAT IS, THE ONGOING
EXPLOITATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
LEMON LAW, WHERE DRAWN OUT
LITIGATION DENIES AND DELAYS THE
VERY RELIEF REQUESTED BY
CONSUMERS AND INCREASES THE COST
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
AMENDMENT. THIS BILL WILL WORSEN
THE STATUS QUO. FOR EXAMPLE, IN
ADDITION TO INTRODUCING VAGUE
AND FLAWED LANGUAGE INTO THE
CODE, IT FAILS TO REQUIRE
PRE-SUIT NOTICE OF ALL SBA
CLAIMS. IT FAILS TO REQUIRE A
VEHICLE BE AVAILABLE FOR
INSPECTION, AND IT FAILS TO
DEFINE A COMPLIANT OFFER.
INSTEAD, IT CODIFIES ADDITIONAL
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND IMPOSES
DISPROPORTIONATE AND DRACONIAN
EVIDENTIARY SANCTIONS AGAINST
MANUFACTURERS THAT WILL BE
MANIPULATED BY TRIAL ATTORNEYS
INSTEAD OF STREAMLINING
RESOLUTIONS. THIS BILL WILL
ENTRENCH THE VERY PROBLEMS IT
SEEKS TO SOLVE. THE CITIZENS OF
THIS STATE, CONSUMERS AND
INDUSTRY ALIKE, NEED FOR YOU TO
TAKE THE TIME TO REFINE THIS
BILL WITH INPUT FROM ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES, TO ENSURE IT
GENUINELY BENEFITS THE CONSUMERS
IT IS MEANT TO SERVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
CONSIDERATION. I'LL BE HERE AND
AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT,
ALL THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED, IF
YOU WOULD APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. CHAIR
MEMBERS. NICOLE HERNANDEZ,
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR TOYOTA.
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. LIZZIE
KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF TESLA
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS PAM
CHAU HIÆN. I REPRESENT THOUSANDS
OF CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE PAST 1012 YEARS, AND A
FORMER DEFENSE ATTORNEY
REPRESENTED FORD IN LEMON LAW
CASES. AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEGAN MURRAY WITH THE
WHITMAN GROUP, ON BEHALF OF
LUCID AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, KERRY FOWLER, ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN HONDA, THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING. GOOD
AFTERNOON, LINDA WHITE, BMW IN
OPPOSITION. FRAWLEY'S GÂY WITH
GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF OF
KIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KURT CAMPBELL. SHU,
ON BEHALF OF SCOUT MOTORS,
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING. NO, NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR ASHBY. ALL
RIGHT. SO I A FEW QUESTIONS.
FIRST OF ALL, FRESHMAN FRESHMAN
SENATOR. SO FIRST END OF TWO
YEAR SESSION. SO MAYBE I'M THE
ONLY ONE THAT FEELS 1,000%
JAMMED UP. BUT NEW FOR ME, NOT
NEW FOR SOME MEMBERS HERE. IN
LOOKING AT THE LAW THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, ONE
OF THE FIRST ISSUES I HAVE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT THE WARRANTIES,
BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE
ABOUT ASSURING THAT PEOPLE DON'T
MAKE THE WARRANTY SHORTER OR
EXACTLY. WARRANTIES ARE VARIED.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU COULD HAVE A
BUMPER TO BUMPER WARRANTY FOR
THREE YEARS, BUT LET'S SAY YOUR
COOLING SYSTEM GOES OUT AND IT
GETS FIXED. YOU NOW HAVE A ONE
YEAR WARRANTY ON THE FIXED PARTS
THAT THEY PUT IN. IF THAT BREAKS
AGAIN THE NEXT YEAR AND YOU FIX
IT AGAIN, YOU HAVE ANOTHER ONE
YEAR WARRANTY AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN. SO WHICH
WARRANTY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
THE WARRANTY THAT YOU ORIGINALLY
PURCHASED WITH YOUR CAR OR THE
WARRANTY THAT YOU GOT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN ON THE PART THAT
BROKE? AND IF IT IS THE LATTER,
IF THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE THREE
YEARS OR THE SIX YEARS OF THE
ORIGINAL WARRANTY PERIOD, THEN
ARE YOU NOW PRECLUDED FROM BEING
ABLE TO ADVANCE A LEMON LAW
CLAIM? BECAUSE THAT'S A REAL
ISSUE, BECAUSE MOST CONSUMERS
SAY, THIS PART ISN'T WORKING ON
MY CAR. LET ME GET IT FIXED.
OKAY? IT'S WORKING NOW. AND THEN
A YEAR LATER, IT'S NOT WORKING
AGAIN. LET ME SEE IF I CAN FIX
IT AGAIN AND THEY WILL GIVE THE
CAR COMPANY OR THE AUTO MECHANIC
AS MANY CHANCES AS THEY CAN. SO
LONG AS IT'S UNDER WARRANTY. SO
AT WHAT POINT DOES THAT PROCESS
BUTT UP AGAINST A PERSON'S RIGHT
TO CLAIM THAT ACTUALLY THEY
BOUGHT A LEMON CAR TO BEGIN
WITH, I'LL ALLOW MY WITNESS TO
ELABORATE SINCE HE DID ALLOW
THEM, BUT BUT, AS IT CURRENTLY
STATES, IT'S ONE YEAR AFTER THE
FINAL WARRANTY EXPIRES OR SIX
YEARS TOTAL FROM DELIVERY OF
VEHICLE. SO, SENATOR ASHBY,
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION. BUT IT
DOESN'T AFFECT THE WHAT THIS LAW
DOES IS IT AFFECTS THE RIGHTS TO
CIVIL PENALTIES IN LEMON LAW. IT
DOESN'T AFFECT YOUR WARRANTY
RIGHTS, YOUR WARRANTY RIGHTS
DON'T CHANGE. SO IF YOUR CAR
BREAKS DOWN THE PRESCRIBED
AMOUNT OF TIMES UNDER THE TANNER
ACT, YOU STILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BRING A CIVIL PENALTY AGAINST
THE INDIVIDUAL. AS LONG AS YOU
FILE A EMAIL OR SEND A LETTER TO
THEM AND SAY, THIS IS A LEMON,
PLEASE BUY IT BACK. THERE'S NO
MAGIC WORDS TO IT, AND THEN YOU
STILL HAVE A RIGHT TO FILE FOR
THE CIVIL PENALTIES. NOTHING
ELSE IS CHANGING EXCEPT THE
RIGHTS TO CIVIL PENALTIES. TELL
ME YOUR NAME AGAIN. MY NAME IS
GREG RIZZIO, MA'AM. GREG RIZZIO.
MR. RIZZIO, THAT WASN'T THE
QUESTION. THE QUESTION IS WHICH
WARRANTY RULES? ALL WARRANTIES
ARE NOT AFFECTED. SO SURE. WELL,
I MEAN, I WASN'T IN THE ROOM.
SOMEBODY SHOULD USE THE MIC. HE
NEEDS A MIC. WE BOTH ARE. FIRST
OF ALL, SO ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
LARA, WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
TO QUESTION NUMBER ONE? AND
NUMBER TWO, WHOEVER DOES
RESPOND, I THINK THAT'S THE
OPPOSITION WANTS TO A CHANCE TO
RESPOND AS WELL. SENATOR SIR, WE
NEED YOU TO HAVE THE MICROPHONE
TO GIVE US YOUR NAME. SURE, MY
NAME IS PAM SHANAHAN. I
REPRESENT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
STRATEGIC LEGAL PRACTICES. WE'VE
REPRESENTED MORE CONSUMERS THAN
ANYONE REGARDING LEMON LAW IN
THE PAST TEN YEARS, AND MY FIRM
WASN'T IN THE ROOM, AND NOBODY
KNOWS THE LEMON LAW ATTORNEYS
WHO WERE IN THE ROOM, WHO
NEGOTIATED THIS. AND LET ME JUST
TELL YOU, UNDER THIS BILL,
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT, THAT
YOU BROUGHT UP. RIGHT? BECAUSE
YOU HAVE ONE WARRANTY, YOU HAVE
ONE LEMON CAR. AND THIS BILL
PROVIDES DIFFERENT STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS FOR DIFFERENT
WARRANTIES. AND NO ONE KNOWS
WHAT THAT IS. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE, YOU KNOW, THE
COMMITTEE IS CONCERNED ABOUT
TRYING TO STREAMLINE LITIGATION.
THIS WILL BASICALLY INCREASE
LITIGATION NOW BECAUSE WHICH
WARRANTY IS IT? DID THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATION ON THIS WARRANTY
EXPIRE AND NOT THE OTHER? YOU
COULD HAVE A CAR WITH LIKE 7 OR
8 BATTERY COMPLAINTS WITHIN THE
FIRST 224 YEARS. AND SOMEBODY
FILES A, YOU KNOW, A LAWSUIT
BECAUSE THEIR TRANSMISSION GAVE
UP AFTER THREE TIMES, AND THEN
THE ENTIRE CAR IS A LEMON AND
YOU'LL HAVE THE OTHER SIDE
ARGUING ABOUT THE FACT THAT,
WELL, THERE IS A STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AND I'M A LAWYER. A
LEMON LAW CLAIM HAS ONE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS. YOU DON'T GO
AHEAD AND GET A LEMON LAW CLAIM
AND APPLY DIFFERENT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS TO DIFFERENT
WARRANTIES IS ONE WARRANTY. I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER, BECAUSE
THAT WAS MY CONCERN, IS THAT
IT'S VERY UNCLEAR WHICH WARRANTY
PREVAILS AS TO THESE NEW TIME
LIMITS, AND WHETHER OR NOT IT
CHANGES THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS LIKE SIX YEARS. THEN
THEY SHOULD HAVE JUST SAID SIX
YEARS. UNDERSTOOD? OKAY AND THEN
THANK YOU, CHAIR. OKAY. AND THEN
MY SECOND CONCERN IS THAT IT
APPEARS TO SHIFT QUITE A BIT OF
BURDEN TO THE CONSUMER. SO THE
CONSUMER NEEDS TO GIVE NOTICE IN
WRITING AT A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME TO THE MANUFACTURER 30 DAYS
PRIOR TO THE ACTION, LAYING OUT
THE VEHICLE INFORMATION SUMMARY
OF PROBLEMS. IT REALLY ASKS THE
CONSUMER OF THE VEHICLE TO HAVE
A LOT OF INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
VEHICLE, AND REALLY UNDERSTAND,
HOW THE PROBLEM IS MECHANICAL
AND MAKES IT A LEMON, AS OPPOSED
TO JUST THE AVERAGE CONSUMER OF
A VEHICLE WHO SAYS IT'S MAKING A
CLUNKY SOUND. SO I'M NOT SURE
HOW YOU WOULD EXPECT A PERSON TO
KNOW THAT INFORMATION AND THEN
CONVEY IT IN A TIMELY FASHION TO
THE ENTITY. SO I'M A LITTLE
WORRIED ABOUT THE SHIFTING
BURDEN. I'M A LITTLE WORRIED
ABOUT THE WARRANTY TERM. I'M A
LITTLE WORRIED ABOUT THE
FUZZINESS OF HOW THIS BILL
INTERPLAYS WITH EXISTING LAW,
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE NOT
CHANGING ALL OF LEMON LAW,
YOU'RE JUST CHANGING A PORTION
OF IT. YOU'RE TRYING TO SPEED IT
UP. BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
SPEEDING IT UP BENEFITS
CALIFORNIANS. I HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT, AND MAYBE THEY COULD
ALL BE ANSWERED IF THIS WAS
JULY. BUT IT'S NOT. IT'S THE
LAST WEEK OF AUGUST, SO WE HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. AND THAT'S IF MR.
EMBERG DOESN'T, YOU KNOW, GET A
HOOK ON ME BEFORE SOON. I DO
WORRY ABOUT PEOPLE SHORTENING
THE TERM OF THE OVERALL
WARRANTY, BECAUSE I THINK THEN
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THEM AN EVEN
SHORTER WINDOW THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO PROVIDE THIS ADDITIONAL
HELP AND THEN I GUESS LASTLY,
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS, IF THIS
BILL PASSES TODAY, IF I VOTE ON
THIS BILL TODAY, IT WOULD BE MY
EXPECTATION THAT THERE WOULD BE
FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION NEXT YEAR,
THAT THERE WOULD BE CLEANUP
LEGISLATION, THAT THERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN. AND THEN LASTLY, AND
THIS IS JUST FOR ME AGAIN, I BEG
YOUR INDULGENCE, NEW SENATOR. I
TRY TO MAKE EVERY DECISION BASED
ON ONE ENTITY, AND IT IS NONE OF
YOU UNLESS YOU HAPPEN TO LIVE IN
MY DISTRICT, WHICH MANY OF YOU
DO. IT'S ALL ABOUT MY
CONSTITUENTS. THAT'S IT. I DON'T
CARE WHAT FORD OR TESLA OR GM OR
THE JUDGES OR THE TRIAL LAWYERS
THINK. I CARE ABOUT WHAT
SACRAMENTO SENATE DISTRICT EIGHT
MEMBERS WILL HAVE TO DO WHEN I
VOTE YES ON THIS. AND MY EYES
THAT WENT TO MCGEORGE. SO, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S HARVARD'S IN THE
ROOM. I'M JUST I'M JUST A
MCGEORGE KNIGHT STUDENT WHO WAS
A MOM. BUT WHAT I RECALL IS THIS
I THINK THIS MAKES IT HARDER.
YEAH. SO I'M A LITTLE WORRIED
ABOUT THAT. AND I WOULD BE
FAIRLY INSISTENT THAT IN THE
FUTURE, WE TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
HOW WE DON'T OVERBURDEN
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY GOT SOLD A CAR THAT'S NOT
GREAT, AND THEY DIDN'T FIGURE IT
OUT IN TIME. AND THAT TIME
PASSED THEM BY. I'M ALSO A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE SUPPORTING
HAVING MORE CLAIMS THAN THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT
SUPPORTING, HAVING FEWER CLAIMS.
THAT'S A RED FLAG. BUT AGAIN,
IT'S MONDAY OF THE LAST WEEK OF
SESSION, SO I DIGRESS. SO, LET
ME LET ME FOR AVOIDANCE OF
DOUBT, I NO LONGER HAVE A HOOK,
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO IS
SENATOR ASHBY. DID YOU WANT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALL TO RESPOND
OR WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE HERE IN
TERMS OF THE ORIGINAL QUESTION,
HE CERTAINLY CAN. BUT HE DID
RESPOND, I THINK WHILE YOU WERE
READING SOME DOCUMENTS AND SO
DID HIS HIS FOLKS. BUT I'M HAPPY
TO HEAR ANYTHING ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO ADD IF ON THE ON THE ON
THE POINT OF SHIFTING BURDENS,
IT'S NOT SHIFT BURDENS. THERE'S
A NOTICE REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD
BE IN EXISTENCE, BUT IT DOESN'T
SHIFT. I MEAN, THIS IS REALLY
THIS BILL MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE, IS ABOUT PROCESS. AND
YOU'RE CORRECT THAT SOME OF THE
MANUFACTURERS AND SUPPORT DO
HAVE MORE OF THE CLAIMS. THEY
ALSO SELL A LARGE QUANTITY OF
THE CARS, BUT THE THREE AMERICAN
MANUFACTURERS AND SUPPORT, I
THINK, COVER OVER 60% OF THE
CASES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
CLOGGING THE SYSTEM. THIS THE
WAY THIS IS WRITTEN, WILL GET
EITHER MONEY OR A NEW CAR INTO
CONSUMER'S HANDS MUCH MORE
QUICKLY THAN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
BASED UPON HOW IT'S BEING
CLOGGED UP. AND, GREG, DO YOU
WANT TO SPEAK TO THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FROM THE CONSUMER?
THE BURDEN ON THE CONSUMER?
SENATOR, SENATOR ASHBY, THERE IS
A NOTICE REQUIREMENT ALREADY.
THE ONLY CHANGE THEY HAVE TO
THEY HAVE TO PICK UP THE PHONE
NOW AND MAKE A PHONE CALL TO THE
MANUFACTURER. THE ONLY CHANGE IS
NOW THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO AN
EMAIL AND IT DOESN'T CHANGE
WARRANTIES. IT CHANGES YOUR
RIGHT ONLY TO OBTAIN CIVIL
PENALTIES. YOU CAN STILL ALWAYS
FILE A LAWSUIT AND WARRANTIES
DON'T CHANGE. YOUR QUESTION IS
WHEN WARRANTIES HAPPEN, THAT
WARRANTY IS STILL IN EFFECT. LET
ME ASK YOU A QUESTION. THIS
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A CONSUMER
TO PROVIDE WRITTEN NOTICE TO THE
MANUFACTURER AT LEAST 30 DAYS
PRIOR TO THE ACTION, LAYING OUT
THE VEHICLE INFORMATION,
INCLUDING A SUMMARY OF THE
PROBLEMS, A REPAIR HISTORY OF
THE VEHICLE, AND THAT THAT
CONSUMER DEMAND THAT THE
MANUFACTURER REPURCHASE OR
REPLACE A MOTOR VEHICLE. IS THAT
A CURRENT REQUIREMENT AS STATED?
RIGHT NOW? THAT IS NOT OKAY.
THEN IT'S A SHIFT. OKAY, LET I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE FINISHED.
IF YOU FINISHED YOUR ANSWER, I
CAN ANSWER IT. OKAY. GO AHEAD
AND FINISH YOUR ANSWER. BUT IT
IS A REQUIREMENT IF YOU WANT
CIVIL PENALTIES TO PUT THEM ON
NOTICE. OTHERWISE YOU DO NOT GET
THAT. ALL RIGHT OKAY. OTHER
QUESTIONS. YES. SENATOR STERN,
I'LL PULL THAT THREAD A LITTLE
FURTHER. I APPRECIATE THE,
DILIGENCE FROM MY COLLEAGUE, BUT
ALSO, I KNOW WE'VE GOT BOTH
AUTHORS HERE, SO I WANT TO SORT
OF PUT, TRY TO HONE IN ON THAT
TENSION AND WHAT THE OPENNESS IS
AMONGST THE PARTIES AROUND
RESOLVING THAT SORT OF IF IT'S
NOT BURDEN SHIFTING THAT IT'S
BURDENSOME. IF YOU WILL, ON THE
NOTICE PIECE. I THINK I THINK I
SEE YOUR AUTHOR'S POINT ON, THAT
THE EVIDENTIARY BURDEN HASN'T
SHIFTED, BUT THAT THIS NOTICE
REQUIREMENT WOULD SOMEHOW BE
HARDER THAN IT IS NOW. THE
SUBSTANCE OF THAT ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION. MAY I ASK THE
AUTHOR OF THE LEAD, IS THAT MORE
THAN CURRENTLY REQUIRED WHEN YOU
HAVE TO MAKE THAT PHONE CALL?
NOW MAYBE. YEAH. IS THE SUMMARY
OF THE ALL THE SORT OF SUBSTANCE
IN THAT NOTICE. IS THAT A
DIFFERENT SET OF ELEMENTS THAN
WHAT IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED UNDER
CURRENTLY, THE CONSUMERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO PICK UP THE PHONE
AND MAKE A COMPLAINT AND ASK TO
HAVE THE CAR BROUGHT BACK. THERE
ARE A LOT OF HIGH FILING FIRMS
THAT ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THAT SYSTEM, AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE PROCESSES OF LITIGATION. SO
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS
YES, THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO GIVE
ALL THAT INFORMATION ALREADY.
BUT IT'S NOW IN AN EMAIL FORM.
AND 49 OTHER STATES ACTUALLY
HAVE A MAIL IN PROCESS. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. MR. CHAIR, CAN I ASK
THE. MR. CHAIRMAN, JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT, IS THAT ALL
RIGHT? I WANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE JUST BECAUSE YOU
WERE YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT A
BROADER PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE
UNDERLYING THIS, WHICH IS THAT
MANUFACTURERS ARE CURRENTLY
MOTIVATED GIVEN THE STRUCTURE OF
THE LAW. I JUST WANT TO ASK,
MISS SHAHEEN, JUST REAL QUICK,
IF YOU DON'T MIND. THANK YOU,
BUT YEAH, JUST TO CAN YOU GIVE
US THAT WE, WE TRUST CARS ON
THESE CONSUMER ISSUES. IT'S A
VERY REPUTABLE ORGANIZATION AND
KNOWN FOR INTEGRITY AND
INDEPENDENCE HERE. NOT HAVING A
PROFIT MOTIVE PER SE. RIGHT, AND
THOSE PROFIT MOTIVES ABOUND,
RIGHT? THEY'RE THEY'RE
EVERYWHERE. SO NO, NO, NO ONE
BEGRUDGING ANYONE'S PROFIT
MOTIVES. IT'S JUST RESPONDING TO
THE STRUCTURES THAT WE HAVE
BUILT. SO BUT I, ARE WE GOING TO
GET A SITUATION WHERE IF YOU'RE
MAKING GOOD CARS, YOU'RE GOING
TO, IF YOU'RE MAKING CARS THAT
YOU KNOW, ARE LEMONS AT LOWER
RATES, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE LESS
INCENTIVE TO DO SO IN
CALIFORNIA. OR IS IT CAN YOU CAN
YOU JUST FLESH THAT OUT? AND I
GUESS IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT TO
ON WHAT THE IF I CAN GO BACK TO
THE CARS REPRESENTATIVE FIRST,
ON THE SUBSTANCE LIKE THE BURDEN
QUESTION. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR. AND, AND SENATOR
ASHBY AS WELL, YOU'RE ASKING
REALLY GREAT QUESTIONS, SO, YES,
IT WOULD SHIFT THE BURDEN. AND
SO FOR DECADES, I'VE MET WITH
THE AUTO MANUFACTURERS AND THEY
WANTED TO GET THIS WRITTEN.
NOTICE REQUIREMENT IN. AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT WHAT IS
DRIVING A LOT OF THIS ISN'T THE
AMOUNT OF LEMON LAW LITIGATION
PER SE, WHICH IS TEENY TINY
COMPARED TO HOW MANY CARS THEY
SELL. LIKE DURING A THREE YEAR
PERIOD, MANUFACTURERS SOLD 7
MILLION NEW CARS IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE ABOUT 35,000 LEMON
LAWSUITS, WHICH IS A FRACTION OF
1%. AND THE INCREASE, TO A GREAT
EXTENT IS BECAUSE SOME LEMON LAW
FIRMS ARE ADVERTISING IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. SO A LOT OF
CONSUMERS WHO DIDN'T USED TO GET
REPRESENTATION ARE NOW BEING
REPRESENTED LIKE ONE OF THE MOST
ACTIVE LEMON LAW FIRMS IN THE
STATE IS REPRESENT ABOUT 70% OF
THEIR CLIENTS ARE SPANISH
SPEAKING, SO NOW THEY KNOW THEY
HAVE RIGHTS. AND TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT, WHETHER
MANUFACTURERS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR WARRANTIES
WHEN CONSUMERS DON'T HAVE TO
GIVE THEM A FORMAL NOTICE? YES,
OF COURSE. AND WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CONSUMERS
WHO NEVER TALK TO AN ATTORNEY.
BUT I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR CAR
FIXED AND RIGHT NOW, SINCE 1970,
IF THE MANUFACTURER DOESN'T
PROMPTLY GIVE THEM A REFUND OR
REPLACEMENT WITH JUST AN
INFORMAL COMMUNICATION, LIKE
THROUGH THEIR DEALERS, YOU KNOW,
THE COURT FOUND IN THE CROTON
DECISION, WHICH DATES BACK
DECADES, THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE CLAIRVOYANT TO KNOW THE CAR
IS A LEMON. YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
PROACTIVELY, ACTIVELY WITHOUT
THE ATTORNEY. THE CONSUMER
HAVING TO DO ANYTHING MAJOR.
TAKE CARE OF IT. YOU KNOW, LIKE
TOYOTA WOULD SELDOM GET SUED
UNDER THE LEMON LAW. THEY'LL
SEND IT TO TROUBLESHOOTER. THEY
BUILD A DISTRIBUTION CENTER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
DISTRIBUTE PARTS SO THAT THEY
COULD GET THEM OUT. REALLY FAST.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS, LIKE,
FORD, WHICH IS SUPPORTING THE
BILL. LAST YEAR, THEY PAID $1.6
BILLION IN WARRANTY COSTS.
THEY'RE APOLOGIZING ALL OVER TO
THE MEDIA. YEAH, WE KNOW WE HAVE
HUGE QUALITY PROBLEMS. THEY
ISSUED 56 SAFETY RECALLS
AFFECTING 5.7 MILLION VEHICLES
WITH SERIOUS DEFECTS. LIKE THE
STEERING WHEEL COMES OFF IN YOUR
HANDS. AND THAT'S VERY COSTLY
FOR THEM. THEY WANT TO REDUCE
THOSE COSTS, NOT HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THEIR WARRANTIES FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CONSUMERS ARE
NOT GOING TO FIGURE OUT. IT'S
NOT ENOUGH JUST TO TELL THE
DEALER ANYMORE. IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO CALL THE MANUFACTURERS TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND TALK TO THEIR
SERVICE REPS. YOU'VE GOT TO
WRITE SOMETHING. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND JUST TO WRAP UP, I
GUESS AT THAT POINT, IS THERE
WAS THAT AN IMPORTANT DEAL POINT
THAT THAT EMAIL COMMUNICATION
ALONE AND EXACTLY WHAT WAS IN
THAT EMAIL COMMUNICATION, WAS
THAT CENTRAL TO THE DEAL BEING
REACHED, OR IS THERE TO SENATOR
ASHBY'S POINT ABOUT THERE COULD
BE FOLLOW ON TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT MECHANISM, THAT CONTACT
MECHANISM IS EASY AS POSSIBLE.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, LIKE THAT
DEALERSHIP EXAMPLE WAS THAT
THOUGHT ABOUT IN A NONSTARTER OR
IS THE DEALER IS LIKE HAVING A
FEW POINTS OF ENTRY? NOT REALLY
AS BIG OF A STICKING POINT AFTER
ALL. YEAH. IF I MIGHT, MIKE, ON
BEHALF OF GM, YES, IT WAS A IT
WAS A SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE
DISCUSSION. 49 STATES REQUIRE
SOME FORM OF WRITTEN NOTICE AND
IT GOES TO WILLFULNESS. DID YOU
INTENTIONALLY FAIL TO HONOR YOUR
WARRANTY OBLIGATION OR YOU
DIDN'T? WHICH IS WHAT LEADS TO
THE CIVIL PENALTIES FOR THE
FIRST TIME, THERE IS NO DEADLINE
AT ALL ON MANUFACTURERS NOW TO
RESPOND. THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
IN CALIFORNIA LAW THAT A STRICT
30 DAY DEADLINE WILL KICK IN.
YOU HAVE TO TELL THE CONSUMER,
YES, WE BELIEVE YOU HAVE A LEMON
AND WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU A
REPLACEMENT CAR OR A FULL
BUYBACK, AND WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT WITHIN ANOTHER 30 DAYS. SO
WITHIN 60 DAYS WE'RE GOING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER YOU HAVE A
LEMON AND TAKE CARE OF IT. AND
THAT'S THE FIRST TIME THERE HAS
BEEN A DEADLINE IN CALIFORNIA
LAW. BUT WE THINK IT IS FAIR AND
IN ACCORD WITH 49 OTHER STATES
TO INSTEAD OF HAVING TO SIFT
THROUGH THE MILLIONS OF CALLS
THAT COME INTO A CALL CENTER, A
SIMPLE EMAIL, I THINK I HAVE A
LEMON. I NEED A BUYBACK. I TOOK
IT TO THE DEALER THREE TIMES.
THEY SAID YES. THANK YOU, SO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN ISSUE, YOU
KNOW, IN THIS BUILDING, WE
CONSTANTLY TALK ABOUT GOING
GREEN, AND I ALWAYS ARGUE THE
FACT THAT THIS IS AMERICA, WE'RE
ALL DRIVING SOMEWHERE IN MY
DISTRICT. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT COMMUTE
OUTSIDE OF THE DISTRICT INTO MY
DISTRICT FOR JOBS. YOU KNOW, I
FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE I USED TO
LIVE BEFORE THIS JOB, I WOULD
DRIVE THREE HOURS A DAY, AN HOUR
AND A HALF EACH WAY TO AND FROM
MY JOB. A CAR IS INCREDIBLY
VITAL TO ALL PEOPLE, LET ALONE
THE WORKING CLASS AND THOSE THAT
ARE LIVING EVEN FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY. WE HAVE ONE OF THE
GREATEST AMERICAN CAR
MANUFACTURERS IN THE WORLD,
SUGGESTING THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE PUSH AVERAGE
WARRANTIES THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IS THREE YEARS OR YOU
KNOW, 36,000 MILES, SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
MORE MAYBE, SO FORTH. THIS HAS
NOT BEEN TOUCHED IN DECADES. THE
REALITY IS THAT RIGHT NOW, IF
AND I'M GOING TO SPEAK FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. SO MY VERY
FIRST CAR THAT I PURCHASED, I
HAD A BEATER FOR A VERY LONG
TIME, AND I EVENTUALLY PURCHASED
A CAR. THIS WAS LIKE MAYBE IN
COLLEGE. AND THIS VEHICLE WAS
BRAND NEW AND IT KEPT HAVING
LITTLE ISSUES. RIGHT. AND I HAD
NO IDEA WHAT THE ISSUES WERE.
TOOK IT TO THE DEALERSHIP
MULTIPLE TIMES. EVENTUALLY IT
HIT OVER THE WARRANTY MILE
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES. NOT BEING
ADDRESSED THE VERY FIRST TIME.
AND AS A PERSON WHO, YOU KNOW,
IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT THE
CONSUMER, THE RIGHT TO
REPRESENTATION, HAVING TO PAY
FOR THAT REPRESENTATION, HAVING
TO FIND THAT REPRESENTATION,
HAVING TO EXPLAIN THE PROBLEM,
AND MUCH MORE. AND EVEN CALLING
THE MANUFACTURER AND SAYING, HEY,
THERE'S A18 HUNDRED NUMBER AND
GOING THROUGH THAT, IT'S A
PROCESS ALREADY. AND TO BE QUITE
FRANK, IT'S A PROCESS, RIGHT? IT
DOES NOT SERVE THE CONSUMER.
IT'S NOT ANSWERED. IT'S THE
PHONE CALLS ARE IGNORED,
REJECTED, AND THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
IS DEVELOPED TO NOT HAVE TO DO
WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CONSUMER. THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY HAVING TODAY. TO BE
COMPLETELY FRANK, AN EMAIL I
WOULD PREFER I WOULD PREFER
SENDING AN EMAIL SAYING I BOUGHT
A CAR AT THIS TIME. I TOOK IT
TO, YOU KNOW, WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW, SOME MANUFACTURER OR SOME
AUTO BODY SHOP OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT TO FIX THIS. IT HAS NOT
BEEN FIXED. IN FACT, I GOT AN
ESTIMATE FROM AN OUTSIDE PARTY
THAT HAS TAKEN PHOTOS. HERE ARE
THE ATTACHMENTS. LET ME FORWARD
YOU THIS EMAIL. IT IS FRIENDLIER
TO THE CONSUMER IN THIS
SUGGESTED MANNER. THAT'S THE
HONEST TRUTH. YES. ARE THERE
CLEANUPS? I'M SURE YOU KNOW A
BIG CHANGE OF A BILL OR A LAW
THAT HASN'T BEEN TOUCHED IN
DECADES OF COURSE YOU KNOW,
THERE'S NOT YOU KNOW, IT IS LAST
MINUTE. RIGHT, AND I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE WORKED ON IT FOR
MONTHS, BUT FOR US, WE HAVEN'T
NECESSARILY SEEN IT OR HAD ALL
OUR, YOU KNOW, QUESTIONS
ANSWERED. BUT TO ME, BEING ABLE
TO SEND AN EMAIL AT 11:00 AT
NIGHT AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
ANSWER OR HAVE SOMEBODY ON THE
PHONE, THIS SERVES MY PURPOSE. I
CAN SEND PHOTOS, I CAN SAY THIS,
AND I CAN SAY THAT THE VEHICLE
MILEAGE IS AT THIS POINT,
INITIATING A 100% THAT I NEED
HELP BEFORE IT HITS ITS
WARRANTY, OR RIGHT WHEN IT WAS
IN WARRANTY AND SHOW
DOCUMENTATION AND MUCH MORE. I
THINK THAT THIS IS INCREDIBLY
FAIR. I THINK, YES, WE STILL
HAVE WORK TO DO AND WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE CONSUMERS TO ME, TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU, AND I'M
SURPRISED THAT, YOU KNOW, ALL
OUR ALL OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
FRIENDS HAVEN'T BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS THAT WARRANTY
SHOULD BE AT MINIMUM TEN YEARS
SOLID. THAT IS A HUGE
INVESTMENT. EVEN THE CHEAPER
CARS THAT ARE $20,000 SHOULD
LAST A PERSON 20 YEARS, TEN
YEARS, WHATEVER THE CASE IS. BUT
NOT THESE THREE YEARS, 36
MONTHS, X, Y, AND Z. WE HAVE NOT
BEEN FRIENDLY TO CONSUMER. WE'RE
BASICALLY BUY AND SELL THE CAR
TO GET A REACTION FROM THE
MANUFACTURER WITHIN 30 TO 60
DAYS. THE WAY IT'S OUTLINED IS
VERY FAIR AND IT ALLOWS A PERSON
TO GET BACK ON THE ROAD TO DO
THEIR JOB AND CARE ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
THEM. SO I WILL MOVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WAHAB. OTHER QUESTIONS.
SENATOR ROTH AND SENATOR ALLEN
THEN. OH, I'M SORRY, I, SENATOR
RUSSO, ACTUALLY RAISED HER HAND
FIRST. SO SENATOR ROSSO, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW ABOUT WHAT
APPEARS TO BE, STRONG.
PROTECTIONS FOR THE FOR THE
CONSUMER. SOUNDS VERY FAIR. BUT,
THE AUTHOR WHO AUTHORS BUT THIS
AUTHOR, I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR. I KNOW THAT YOU AND YOUR
LIFE AND YOUR YOUR COMMITMENT
HOLD THE CONSUMER VERY HIGH. SO
THAT MEANS A LOT TO ME, BUT I'M
A LITTLE BIT THROWN OFF BY WHO'S
FOR AND WHO'S AGAINST. AND IT I
CAN'T MAKE SENSE OF IT. SO AS
YOU WERE GOING THROUGH THIS AND
YOU REACHED AN AGREEMENT ABOUT
LEGISLATION THAT YOU WOULD
PROPOSE, WHAT WHAT ARE THESE
DIFFERENCES FOR EXAMPLE, WITHIN
THE CAR MANUFACTURERS, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S GM THERE'S OTHER
COMPANIES. WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S MOTIVATING
THEM TO EITHER BE FOR OR
AGAINST? WELL, THERE'S YOU KNOW,
I CAN'T SPEAK TO OTHER'S
MOTIVATIONS. I WILL TELL YOU
WHAT MY MOTIVATIONS ARE IN
LEARNING ABOUT THIS NEGOTIATION,
WHICH WAS MANY, MANY MONTHS
LONG, FIRST OF ALL, RIGHT NOW, I
MEAN, I'VE GONE THROUGH A
PROCESS, A LEMON LAW RECALL
PROCESS. I HAD THE NOTIFY THAT I
WANTED TO BE PART OF IT. I WAS
INFORMED BY A COLLEAGUE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND A FEW OF US TOOK
PART IN IT. THE FACT THAT THERE
IS NO BURDEN OF NOTICE RIGHT NOW
ON THE CONSUMER IS JUST,
FRANKLY, NOT TRUE. THERE ARE
STEPS THAT THEY TAKE TO SENATOR
WAHAB'S POINT, I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY SITUATION THESE DAYS
WHERE WE DON'T DOCUMENT THINGS
IN WRITING, USUALLY THROUGH
EMAIL. WE DON'T GO ON THE PHONE
AND SAY, HEY, I HAD AN ISSUE TO
COME UP WITH A REPAIR SHOP. WE
PUT IT IN WRITING BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT PROTECTS US. SO THIS
IS ASKING US TO DO THAT. AND
LET'S KEEP IN MIND RIGHT NOW,
THERE IS NO DEADLINE FOR THE
MANUFACTURER TO RESPOND TO
CONSUMERS. ONCE NOTICE IS MADE.
RIGHT NOW, THERE IS NO DEADLINE.
SO IF YOU CALL AND GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF CALLING, THEY CAN
TAKE WEEKS OR MONTHS. AND WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DELAYING AND THAT'S WHY
OUR COURT SYSTEM IS CLOGGED. 10%
OF CIVIL CASES IN LOS ANGELES
ARE LEMON LAW CASES. THAT IS NOT
GOOD FOR CONSUMERS. SO ARE THERE
SOME THINGS THE MANUFACTURER
LIKES? YES. THAT'S PART OF
NEGOTIATIONS. THAT'S HOW YOU GET
THAT'S WHAT WE DID THAT WITH
PAGA. I WOULD I WAS FINE, I
PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE DONE ALL
THE THINGS I WANTED THAT WE DID
WITH PAGA THE WAY. EXACTLY. IT
WAS DONE. BUT GUESS WHAT? IT'S
NOT ASH KALRA THAT'S THAT'S
NEGOTIATING WITH THEMSELVES.
RIGHT? IN THE SIMILAR SITUATION.
THIS IS A SITUATION HERE THAT I
BELIEVE WILL LEAD TO RESULTS
WHERE CONSUMERS WILL ACTUALLY
GET THEIR END RESULT DONE MUCH
MORE QUICKLY. IT DOESN'T AFFECT
WARRANTIES AT ALL. WARRANTIES
ARE STILL GOING TO WARRANTY LAW
STILL REMAINS COMPLETELY IN
EFFECT. WHAT THIS DOES, IT
ACTUALLY SPEEDS UP THE PROCESS
OF HAVING MANUFACTURERS REQUIRES
THEM TO RESPOND WITHIN 30 DAYS.
RIGHT NOW, THERE'S ZERO DEADLINE
FOR THEM TO RESPOND. AND
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT, THERE'S
ANOTHER PROCESS WHERE
ESSENTIALLY WITHIN 60 TO 90
DAYS, UNLESS THERE IS SOME
DISPUTE, A GREATER DISPUTE THAT
THAT IS DETERMINED. THE CONSUMER
IS GOING TO GET THEIR MONEY BACK
OR GET A VEHICLE AND THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. AND GUESS
WHAT? ANOTHER THING THE
MANUFACTURERS TEND TO HAVE A LOT
MORE LAWYERS THAT CAN DRAW THESE
THINGS OUT THAN THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER DOES. AND SO THAT'S
WHERE, YOU KNOW, ULTIMATELY, AND
YOU KNOW, ARE THERE GOING TO BE
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS GOING INTO
THE FUTURE THAT SENATOR UMBERG
AND I ARE GOING TO CERTAINLY
LIKE ANY, ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ESPECIALLY I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP, BECAUSE
THAT WAS A QUESTION, IS THIS IS
BEING DONE AS AN URGENCY. AND,
YOU KNOW, IS THERE AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS COULD
COULD COME UP TO CLEAN UP OR
ADDRESS ISSUES THAT WE WOULD
HAVE KNOWN WE JUST SUBMITTED?
CLARIFYING. YES. I'VE BEEN ON
THE SIDE OF WHERE I'VE BEEN TOLD
NO, THAT'S THAT. DON'T EVEN
THINK ABOUT BRINGING THAT BACK.
AND THERE WAS A QUOTE UNQUOTE
DEAL THAT SORT OF STUFF. SO,
SENATOR, I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU KNOW THIS IN EXCHANGE
FOR THE URGENCY THAT WE REALLY
ARE GOING TO BE OPEN MINDED
ABOUT ANY SENATOR, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THIS IS SOMETHING. AND
I THINK YOU KNOW, MYSELF AND
CHAIR UMBERG WELL ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COME BACK IF THINGS NEED
TECHNICAL CLEANUPS, IF THERE ARE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE FIXED.
THIS MORNING WE TOOK AN
AMENDMENT BASED UPON MEETINGS WE
HAD LAST WEEK FROM SOME OF THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS, TO HELP
ENSURE THAT GAMES CAN'T BE
PLAYED BY LITIGANTS AND
PARTICULARLY BY THE
MANUFACTURERS. AND THE
MANUFACTURERS ACCEPTED THAT
AMENDMENT. AND SO THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE CAN WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON, LIKE ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. I IT WASN'T UP TO
ME THAT THIS THAT THIS
NEGOTIATION TOOK MANY MONTHS. IT
HAPPENED IN THE WAY THAT IT
HAPPENED. AND I'M HOPING THAT BY
COMING TO SOME AGREEMENT THIS
WON'T BECOME A PROLONGED BATTLE,
THAT WE'LL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
RETURN TO THIS LARGER BATTLE,
BUT RATHER JUST WORK ON THE
CLEANUP IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS
AHEAD. THANK YOU. JUST TO
CLARIFY SOMETHING AND YOU'RE
RIGHT, THIS IS A MATTER THAT'S
BEING BROUGHT TO US AT THE VERY
END. BUT THERE IS NO URGENCY
PROVISION IN THE BILL. YES.
THERE'S NO URGENCY. YES. THAT'S
CORRECT. YEAH. CORRECT. CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR ROTH AND
SENATOR ALLEN AND SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU KNOW,
PERHAPS WE SHOULD HAVE PUT A
SUNSET ON THIS AT SOME FOR SOME
LENGTH TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT WAS
GOING TO WORK AND THEN GIVE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT. BUT
HINDSIGHT'S 2020, AND WE DON'T
DO THAT AT THIS POINT IN THE
PROCESS. I WAS A LITTLE CONFUSED
ON THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
WARRANTIES. I LOOKED AT THE
ANALYSIS. THERE'S AN EXPRESS
WARRANTY. MAYBE THERE'S AN
IMPLIED, BUT I DON'T KNOW. I
DIDN'T KNOW, AND I USED TO BE A
LAWYER. I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU WERE
EXCHANGING CONVERSATION WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ABOUT MULTIPLE
WARRANTIES. THE ANALYSIS TALKS
ABOUT THIS BILL REQUIRING
ACTIONS TO BE COMMENCED WITHIN
ONE YEAR AFTER THE EXPIRATION OF
THE APPLICABLE EXPRESS WARRANTY,
BUT NO LATER THAN SIX YEARS
AFTER THE ORIGINAL DELIVERY. ET
CETERA. I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
ABOUT SOME OTHER WARRANTY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A SERVICE
CONTRACT TALKING TO YOU, SIR.
ME? YOU WERE THE ONE THAT WAS
HAVING THE CONVERSATION. YES.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SERVICE
CONTRACT? NO, YOUR HONOR, I'M
NOT. I'M NOT THE HONOR. HE'S THE
HONOR. I'M NOT I APOLOGIZE, SO.
SO WHAT'S. SO A CAR HAS SEVERAL
WARRANTIES, A BUMPER TO BUMPER,
A 12 YEAR BATTERY WARRANTY, AND
A POWERTRAIN WARRANTY. FOR
EXAMPLE, EXPRESS WARRANTIES.
RIGHT? THOSE ARE DIFFERENT
EXPRESS WARRANTIES. ARE THERE
EXPRESS WARRANTIES? RIGHT. SO
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT. RIGHT. SO
LET'S SAY IF YOU HAVE LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE, A CAR THAT HAS THREE
BATTERY COMPLAINTS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR THAT'S COVERED UNDER
THE 12 YEAR, ONE MONTH WARRANTY
AND THEN LET'S SAY YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF AIR CONDITIONING
COMPLAINTS THAT HAPPEN DURING
THE SECOND YEAR OF WARRANTY
THAT'S COVERED UNDER THE BUMPER
TO BUMPER. AND THEN, LET'S SAY
DURING THE FOURTH YEAR AND FIFTH
YEAR, YOU HAVE COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THE POWERTRAIN WARRANTY. SO YOU
HAVE ALL OF THESE COMPLAINTS
REGARDING THE BATTERY. AND THE
ENTIRE CAR IS A LEMON, RIGHT? SO
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE
ALL OF THAT EVIDENCE. AND
THEY'RE NOT AND IT SHOULDN'T BE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT ALL OF THOSE
BATTERY ISSUES THAT YOU HAD
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR, THE THREE
BATTERY REPLACEMENTS AND THE
FACT THAT THIS BATTERY
REPLACEMENT ALSO CAME BACK 4 OR
5 YEARS AGO, 4 OR 5 YEARS LATER,
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, CAME AFTER THE
FIRST YEAR. NONE OF THAT SHOULD
COME IN BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T FILE
YOUR LAWSUIT WITHIN ONE YEAR OF
THAT WARRANTY. SO OF THE
APPLICABLE EXPRESS WARRANTY. SO
IF YOU IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
EXPRESS WARRANTIES, YEAH, IF
THEY PUT IN IF APPLICABLE,
EXPRESS WARRANTY MEANS THE MOST
RECENT WARRANTY IN WHICH THAT
YOU REPORTED THE NONCONFORMITY
WITH. THEN THE CUSTOMER
COMPLAINED ABOUT THE
NONCONFORMITY THAT WOULD BE A
CLARIFICATION THAT SHOULD BE
MADE, DID YOU SUPPLY, CORRECTIVE
OR AMENDING LANGUAGE TO EITHER
THE PEOPLE, THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL OR THE COMMITTEE, WELL,
THE, THE I THINK I BELIEVE MY I
BELIEVE WE DID SUBMIT SOME
LANGUAGE ON THAT ISSUE TO, TO
THE COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY.
WELL, YOU WERE A LITTLE BIT LATE
FOR THAT, WELL, BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T CONSULTED ABOUT THE
BILL. SO LET ME THEN ASK, LET ME
THEN ASK ANOTHER QUESTION. SO
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE CONSUMER
MISSES THE 30 DAY WINDOW, UNDER
CURRENT LAW, LITTLE TIME TO
THINK ABOUT YOUR ANSWER, BECAUSE
WE NEED TO RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES SO THAT THE FLOOR
SESSION HAS STARTED OR WILL
START IN ONE MINUTE. AND THEY
NEED TO SWITCH THE TV CAMERA
OVER TO THE FLOOR VERSUS ALL OF
US GOOD LOOKING PEOPLE HERE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN RECESS NOW
UNTIL 205. ALL RIGHT. I THINK WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO THE FLOOR.
BUT THEY NEED TO SWITCH OVER THE
ELECTRONICS. I AM TOLD. SO WE'RE
WE, SENATOR ROTH, WHEN WE PARTED
COMPANY HERE, SENATOR ROTH HAD
ASKED A QUESTION AND THE
RESPONDENT IS NOT HERE. SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR ROTH. DID YOU
HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS? I CAN JUST
LET ME JUST ADD, I MEAN, MY
UNDERSTANDING OF READING THIS,
IF I READ IT PROPERLY IN THE
TIME THAT I HAD TO READ IT, IS
THE CONSEQUENCE OF NOT
COMPLETING THE 30 DAY NOTICE
RESULTS IN PERHAPS THE INABILITY
TO SECURE THE CIVIL PENALTIES,
WHICH ARE UP TO TWO TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF ACTUAL DAMAGES, BUT
DOES NOT IMPACT THE CONSUMER'S
RIGHT TO OBTAIN EITHER
RESTITUTION, WHICH IS THE MONEY
PAID FOR THE CRAZY AUTOMOBILE.
THAT'S LEMONADE, OR A
REPLACEMENT VEHICLE. IS THAT
CORRECT? AS WELL AS $0.30 AS FAR
AS ATTORNEY'S FEES AS WELL, YOU
CAN STILL RECOVER THOSE. OKAY SO
LET ME JUST SAY THIS. YOU KNOW,
AS A AS A FORMER CUSTOMER OF THE
COURT SYSTEM, AS A FORMER
MANAGER OF A, OF A FIRM THAT
ADMITTEDLY, I CONFESS WHERE I
WAS, BUT SOME OF MY PARTNERS
DEFENDED LEMON LAW CASES FOR ONE
OF THE MAJOR MANUFACTURERS AND
ALSO ARBY'S THAT I WATCHED FROM
AFAR. IT SEEMED LIKE A SORT OF A
COTTAGE INDUSTRY TO ME. BUT ONE
THING THAT DID OCCUR TO ME AS I
WATCHED IT WAS THE NEVER ENDING
STREAM OF DISCOVERY THAT
RESULTED IN THESE CASES, AND I
WATCHED IT BECAUSE I WAS
MANAGING THE FIRM AND TO SOME
EXTENT, IT WASN'T A PROFIT
LEADER. AND SO I WAS INTERESTED
IN WHAT LAWYERS WERE DOING AND
PARALEGALS WERE DOING, WE FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE, WE NEED TO
STREAMLINE THIS THING. AND IF
THERE'S A PROBLEM, SOMEBODY IS
COMPLAINING ABOUT FRONT LOADING
DISCOVERY. WE OUGHT TO FRONT
LOAD THE IMPORTANT PIECES OF
DISCOVERY. WE OUGHT TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE IN THE
CASE FROM BOTH SIDES. BOTH SIDES
OUGHT TO SIT DOWN. IF THERE'S
MEDIATION REQUIRED, THEY OUGHT
TO MEDIATE, AND THEY OUGHT TO
GET THE THING DONE. AND IF YOU
CAN'T SETTLE IT, THEN YOU CAN
CONTINUE ON WITH YOUR DISCOVERY.
BUT IT IS THAT SORT OF LEGAL
ACTIVITY THAT IS CLOGGING OUR
COURT SYSTEM. AND I WAS
PRACTICING IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AT A TIME WHEN IT TOOK OVER FIVE
YEARS TO GET A CIVIL CASE TO
TRIAL. THEY HAD TO START THE
CASE, POSTPONE THE CASE TO TOLL
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ON
PROCEEDING, BRING ANOTHER CASE
IN, AND START ANOTHER CASE IN
THOSE DAYS, I DON'T KNOW IF MR.
VIZIO REMEMBERS THAT, BUT I
CERTAINLY DO. WE CANNOT GO BACK
TO THAT. WE NEED TO STREAMLINE
LITIGATION WHERE POSSIBLE. AND
SO I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY. I WOULD IF WE
COULD AMEND TO HAVE A PERHAPS A
SUNSET. SO WE COULD TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT THIS AND FINE TUNE THE
PROVISIONS, IF IN FACT WE'VE GOT
IT WRONG. BUT WE CAN STILL DO
THAT. I WON'T BE HERE, SOMEONE
ELSE WILL BE HERE NEXT YEAR, AND
THE YEAR AFTER. AND IF, IF, IF
SUMMER RECALL HAS CAUSED A
PROBLEM, WE CAN FIX THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR
LAIRD, THEN SENATOR NIELLO.
GOSH, LET ME START WITH
OPPOSITION. I MEAN, ARE THERE
THINGS CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT WHAT
DO YOU LIKE ABOUT THE BILL ON
THE OPPOSITION SIDE? YEAH SURE,
I'VE, I'VE SPOKEN WITH SOME OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PREVIOUSLY. YOU KNOW, I DO LIKE
THE STREAMLINED DISCOVERY
PROCEDURES, AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE MAKING THE CHANGE AND
AMENDING THE BILL AND NOW SAYING
IT'S BASED ON RESPONSIVE
PLEADING AND THE ANSWER, AND I
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE SANCTIONS
THAT WERE PUT, HOWEVER, EVEN ON
THE DISCOVERY ISSUES. AND I
THINK THIS MAY HAVE BEEN BECAUSE
GM WAS IN THE ROOM AND NOT ALL
THE PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEYS WERE
IN THE ROOM. IS THAT, FOR
EXAMPLE, LIKE WE HAVE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT HAS TO BE
PRODUCED BETWEEN THE CUSTOMER
AND THE MANUFACTURER AND
CUSTOMER AND THE DEALER, BUT
IT'S VERY VAGUE AND AMBIGUOUS AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT DOCUMENTS AND
COMMUNICATIONS REGARDING THE
SUBJECT VEHICLE BETWEEN THE
MANUFACTURER AND THE DEALER HAS
TO BE PRODUCED. AND THAT'S
REALLY THE LEMON LAW CASE,
RIGHT? LIKE THE MANUFACTURERS
AND THE DEALERS TALK ABOUT THE
VEHICLE AND THE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE. SO THERE'S SOME CLARITY
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
INTRODUCED AND IT WOULD BE
BETTER, ALSO, I THINK THERE'S
ALSO PROVISIONS REGARDING THE
DISCOVERY PORTION OF THIS THAT
SAYS RELEVANT DOCUMENTS NEEDS TO
BE PRODUCED. I THINK THEY SHOULD
BE, YOU KNOW, THE CLARIFICATION
BY RELEVANCE, WE MEAN THE
ALLEGATIONS IN THE COMPLAINT AND
THE AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSES RAISED
IN THE ANSWER, NOT WHAT THE
MANUFACTURER THINKS IS RELEVANT
AND JUST PRODUCES IT BASED ON
THEIR OWN THEORY OF THE CASE.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE A
BUNCH OF LITIGATION AND SAY,
WELL, YOU KNOW, THE STATUTE SAYS
WHAT'S RELEVANT THIS IS WHAT WE
THINK IT'S RELEVANT. SO THOSE
ARE SOME STUFF AND I'M SURE, YOU
KNOW, CAC WHO I'M A MEMBER OF,
AND I'M A LITTLE BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT THEY DIDN'T
CONSULT ME WITH THIS OR THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS EVERY DAY. BUT I
THINK THESE ARE ISSUES THAT THE
BILL, YOU KNOW, COULD HAVE BEEN
IMPROVED ON, EVEN WITH THE
DISCOVERY STREAMLINE, WHICH I
SUPPORT, BUT I, YOU KNOW, BUT,
YOU KNOW, BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THAT CAN ALSO GET COURTS
CONGESTED AS WELL. SENATOR, CAN
I ADD GO AHEAD. YES. SENATOR
ALLEN DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION? SENATE-ROOM? WELL, I
MEAN, THERE'S SUCH DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON THAT. THIS IS
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS LIKE THE
AUTOMOBILE INDUSTRY DOESN'T
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. WELL, IT
ANSWERS I HAD ONE MORE. HE
ANSWERED HIS VERSION OF THE
QUESTION. YES IT DID. OH, WHAT
WAS I'M SORRY. NO, NO IT WAS I
MEAN, IT WAS RESPONSIVE FROM HIS.
WOULD YOU LIKE OTHERS TO RESPOND
TO YOUR QUESTION AS WELL? YES,
PLEASE. CAN I JUST ADD ONE MORE
THING TO THAT? SURE. WELL, I
KNOW THE OTHER THING IS TOO. I
DON'T BELIEVE A CUSTOMER SHOULD
BE. I MEAN, UNDER THE CURRENT
BILL IS ALSO VAGUE AND
AMBIGUOUS, WHERE THE CUSTOMER
NOW NEEDS TO GO AND COLLECT ALL
THE REPAIR RECORDS FROM SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AND PRODUCE IT AS PART
OF THE 120 DAYS. AND, YOU KNOW,
I SAW SENATOR WAHAB, WHO BROUGHT
UP A GOOD EXAMPLE. YOU WENT TO
THE DEALER, YOU FOUND OUT YOUR
CAR HAD A PROBLEM, YOU GOT THAT
REPAIR RECORD AND YOU SEND IT TO
THEM. THAT'S GREAT. BUT YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO GO AND
FIND 4 OR 5 YEARS WORTH OF
REPAIR RECORDS AND GIVE IT TO
THEM. AND IF YOU DON'T GIVE IT
TO THEM, THEN NOW THEY'RE GOING
TO FILE ALL OF THESE MOTIONS
SAYING, OH, YOUR CASE SHOULD BE
DISMISSED. YOU DIDN'T GIVE US
THE DOCUMENTS THAT THEY ALREADY
HAVE IN THEIR POSSESSION,
CUSTODY AND CONTROL. SO IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN GREAT. IT'S SAYING,
LOOK, THE MANUFACTURERS SHOULD
MAKE THE FIRST INITIAL
PRODUCTION AND WHATEVER THEY
DON'T PRODUCE AND THE THEY
HAVEN'T PRODUCED, THEN THE
CONSUMER CAN GO AHEAD AND
SUPPLEMENT THAT. ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN,
WOULD YOU LIKE YOUR QUESTION
ANSWERED BY OTHERS? YES, PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I JUST
HAVE TWO QUICK GO AHEAD, IN
TERMS OF ON BEHALF OF THE
MANUFACTURERS, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
14 MANUFACTURERS IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. TWO OF THE THINGS
THAT WE LIKE ARE THE PRE-SUIT
NOTICE, THAT IS A GREAT ADDITION
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT PROVIDES
THE PRE-SUIT NOTICE. NOTICE, IT
PROVIDES A LOT OF CLARITY RIGHT
NOW. CONSUMERS DO NEED TO
CONTACT US, BUT THEY OFTEN DO SO
BY PHONE CALL. AND THEY SAY
THINGS LIKE, I'M UNHAPPY WITH MY
REPAIR HISTORY, I CAN'T, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH MY
CAR. AND THEN JUDGES INTERPRET
THAT AS PRE-SUIT NOTICE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE AFFIRMATIVELY BOUGHT
BACK A CAR WHEN THEY COULD HAVE
JUST BEEN CALLING UP TO ASK A
QUESTION. IT'S A SHAME IT DIDN'T
GET EXPANDED TO ALL SÐNG BEVERLY
CLAIMS IT CURRENTLY UNDER THE
BILL. IT ONLY DEALS WITH ONES
THAT WOULD EVENTUALLY SEEK CIVIL
PENALTIES. THE SECOND THING IS
THAT IS A POSITIVE IS PART OF
THE STREAMLINED DISCOVERY
PROCESS IN THAT DOCUMENTS ARE
DEFINED AND THAT TOPICS ARE
DEFINED. FOR A QUÊ PERSON, MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE DEPOSITION. RIGHT
NOW, WE CAN GET NOTICE OF 90
SEPARATE TOPICS FOR A PPMC
DEPOSITION, AND IT'S A LOT MORE
NARROW IN THIS DOCUMENT. THAT IS
DEFINITELY A POSITIVE, BUT THERE
IS STILL SOME AMBIGUITY HERE, SO
THERE WILL STILL BE MOTIONS TO
COMPEL, CLARIFYING THAT AS I AM
JUST, MENTIONED BECAUSE THEY
WILL NOT ACCEPT WHAT WE PROVIDE
AS A MANUFACTURER AS BEING
REASONABLY RESPONSIVE. SO EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S A STAY FOR OTHER
DISCOVERY, IT WON'T CUT OFF ALL
THE THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE, WHICH IS CLOGGING UP THE
COURT SYSTEM. WE WILL STILL HAVE
MOTIONS TO COMPEL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DID THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, SENATOR ALLEN? GO
AHEAD. YEAH. I MEAN, SURE. I
MEAN, OKAY, I UNDERSTAND
EVERYONE'S IN A BIG RUSH. I
MEAN, WE GOT THIS ANALYSIS AT 10
A.M. THIS MORNING. I HAD NO IDEA
THIS WHOLE NEGOTIATION WAS. I'M
NOT RUSHING YOU. I'M JUST. I
JUST WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S
OTHERS YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO
YOUR QUESTION? YEAH, WELL, OKAY.
MR. LAIRD SEEMS TO WANT TO MOVE
ON. I GET IT. ALL RIGHT. I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE PERSON
WHO'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
RIGHT HERE. OKAY. YOU'RE WITH.
OKAY. I WANTED TO JUST GET THE
JUDGE'S PERSPECTIVE ON, YOU KNOW,
THIS WHOLE A COUPLE, A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP. ONE OF THEM HAVING TO DO
WITH PLAINTIFFS, WELL, LET'S
TALK ABOUT, FIRST OF ALL, CIVIL
PROCEDURE. THERE'S BEEN AN
ARGUMENT MADE THAT THIS IS
REALLY CREATES IT'S SETTING NEW,
NEW, NEW SET OF STANDARDS WITH
REGARDS TO CIVIL PROCEDURE,
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NARROWLY TAILORED
TO THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF
INCIDENT, BUT THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT SLIPPERY SLOPE ISSUES. WAS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WAS
DISCUSSED AROUND THE JUDGES
TABLE? JUDGE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. MIKE BALLOT, SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION, WHO LOOKED
AT THIS VERY INTENSIVELY. THEY
BELIEVE THAT THIS THAT WE ARE
OUR SUGGESTION IS CORRECT. THIS
WILL LEAD A LOT OF CASES OUT
BEFORE A LAWSUIT HAS EVER BEEN
FILED. THIS WILL GIVE A RELIEF
WITHIN TWO MONTHS. IN
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBERS. THEY ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE BREADTH OF
DISCOVERY THAT TO THE EXTENT YOU
CAN STANDARDIZE THIS AND WE'VE
DONE IT BEFORE IN OTHER
CONTEXTS, AND WE'VE DONE IT
EARLY, AS RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR
IN SB TWO, 35 WILL HELP JUDGES
SAY TO THE PARTIES, NO, YOU
DON'T GET WORLDWIDE RECORDS. YOU
GET RECORDS RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
MANUFACTURER AND THE DEALER AND
THE CONSUMER. AND IT'S ON PAGE.
IT'S RIGHT THERE. IT'S PAGE 11,
LINES ONE THROUGH FOUR. IT'S
QUITE CLEAR. IT'S WRITTEN AND
ORAL COMMUNICATIONS, EVERYTHING
YOU KNOW MANUFACTURE ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS TELL THEM. AND
THE MORE WE CAN HAVE AND SO THE
JUDGES BELIEVE THE MORE YOU
COULD STANDARDIZE THIS, THE MORE
THEY CAN GET THROUGH THESE CASES.
AND EVERYONE WINS. SO YES, THEY
LOOKED A LOT AT IT. AND MIKE,
YOU'RE I THOUGHT YOU WERE GM. I
REPRESENT GM AND WE REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION. BOTH HAVE FOR 40
YEARS. OKAY OKAY I GOT NO NO I
MEAN I, YOU KNOW, AS LAWYERS
WE'RE ALWAYS SO CONFUSED BY THE
CONFLICTS. BUT BUT I KNOW THAT'S
HOW IT WORKS HERE. OKAY, LET ME
ASK ABOUT, JUST THE ISSUES OF,
SOME OF THESE ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH, WITH WITH THE RIGHTS OF A
CONSUMER, YOU KNOW, ALL THE
EXTRA PAPERWORK THEY HAVE TO
TURN IN, YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE JUST RAISED BY
BY THE ATTORNEY HERE ABOUT
HAVING TO PROVIDE ALL THIS
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTATION. WOULD
THOSE THINGS DISCUSSED AT THE
JUDGES TABLE AS WELL? I
UNDERSTAND THE CORE CONCERN IS
ABOUT ABOUT CONGESTION IN THE
COURTROOM, BUT, BUT SURELY THESE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE QUESTIONS AND
THESE, ARE IMPORTANT TO THEM. I
KNOW THEY THEY SAID HONESTLY,
SENATOR, THEY SAID THIS IS SORT
OF HOW FEDERAL CIVIL PROCEDURE
WORKS. IF THERE ARE MINOR
DEFECTS IN HOW THE PLAINTIFF
PRESENTS THE CASE, AND OFTEN BY
HIM OR HERSELF, WE GET OVER
THAT. WE TAKE IT AS A COMPLAINT.
THEY SAY, TELL THEM BASICALLY
WHAT YOU TRIED TO DO TO TAKE
CARE OF YOUR CAR. AND THAT'S
AGAIN, JUST FOR THE CIVIL
PENALTIES ISSUE. AND IF YOU TELL
THEM THAT AND THEY RESPOND, THEN
THE 60 DAYS KICKS IN. IF NOT,
YOU, THEY CAN BRING THE FULL
COMPLAINT FOR CIVIL PENALTIES
AND THE WHOLE RANGE OF REMEDIES.
SO YES, THEY THOUGHT A SIMPLE
EXPLANATION FOR WHAT THE
CONSUMER WENT THROUGH WITH THE
MANUFACTURER WAS FAIR.
PRE-LITIGATION RIGHT. OKAY. WAS
THERE TALK AT SOME POINT ABOUT,
I'D LOVE TO JUST I KNOW AT ONE
POINT THERE WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT
SOME SORT OF OPT OUT MECHANISM
WHERE IF THE CONSUMER AND THE
OEM MUTUALLY AGREED, THEY COULD
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT PATH. I'D
LIKE TO ASK ABOUT THAT. AND I
ALSO LIKE TO ASK IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION OF SOME SORT OF
SUNSET GIVEN ALL THE COMPLEXITY
HERE, SO THAT WE CAN AT LEAST
GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS
HAS PLAYED OUT OVER A COUPLE OF
YEARS, AND THEN MAKE A
DETERMINATION LATER AS A, AS A
BODY, AS TO WHETHER WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THE MECHANISM. SO I SAW
YOU MOVE YOUR MIC TO WELL, WE
WEREN'T INVOLVED IN ANY OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS. IT WAS JUST MR.
BILLOT AND HIS THREE CLIENTS WHO
SPOKE IN FAVOR OF THIS TODAY,
BUT THERE IS A PROVISION IN HERE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE VÌ A
STIPULATION OF BOTH PARTIES TO
NOT USE THE STREAMLINED,
AGREEMENT, THE STREAMLINED
LITIGATION PROCEDURES, THAT IS,
IN THIS BILL. SO THERE'S AN
OPTION BY BY BOTH PARTIES, IF
THEY MUTUALLY STIPULATE TO NOT
GO THROUGH THE STREAMLINED
PROCEDURES. YES, SENATOR. IT WAS
A VERY CONTENTIOUS ISSUE. AND WE
DID NEGOTIATE THAT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH. AND IT DID. BOTH SIDES
CAN STIPULATE OUT IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. ALL RIGHT. SO YOU COULD
END UP SEEING TO IF YOU AND IF
YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE A VOLKSWAGEN
PROBLEM, YOU COULD BOTH AGREE TO
GO A DIFFERENT PATH I GUESS. NO,
I MEAN LOOK THEN WE'LL BE IN THE
SAME SITUATION WE ARE IF WE'RE
GOING TO TALK INTO THE
MICROPHONE THAT NO, I MEAN, I
THINK THAT THE ISSUE IS GOING TO
BE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CONSUMERS GIVING THEIR
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS. AND YOU
ASKED ME WHAT I LIKED ABOUT THE
BILL, AND I SAID, I LIKE THE
DISCOVERY PROCEDURES. RIGHT. BUT
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO IF
WE'RE GOING TO PUT SOMETHING IN
THE DISCOVERY PROCEDURES. I
MEAN, WE'VE GOT A SPECIFIC I
MEAN, I'M ALREADY NOT GOING TO
BE ARGUING WITH GM. HE DID NOT
ONCE MENTION THE COMMUNICATION
INCLUDES COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
DEALER AND MANUFACTURER
REGARDING THE SUBJECT VEHICLE.
THESE ARE COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT
OUR CLIENT'S VEHICLE THAT THEY
HAVE IN THEIR DATABASES THAT
THEY RECORD. THEY HAVE ABOUT OUR
CLIENTS. AND THEY DIDN'T EVEN
PUT THAT IN THE BILL. AND HE
JUST WANTS TO GIVE ME THE
COMMUNICATIONS THEY HAVE WITH
THE CUSTOMER AND THE DEALERSHIP.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF PROBLEMS
THAT I WANT TO AVOID IN THE
DISCOVERY PROCESS. AND THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT I LIKE ABOUT
THANK YOU. THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS, I THINK, SENATOR,
IF I COULD INTERJECT, IS THAT,
YES, IF BOTH PARTIES AGREE TO
USE THE OLD PROCESS, THEY CAN
USE THEY CAN BASICALLY DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO. IF
THEY WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW, WE'D
LIKE TO TAKE 50 DEPOSITIONS ON
EACH SIDE. THEY CAN STIPULATE TO
THAT. AND I ASSUME THE JUDGE IS
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND, BASICALLY
RATIFY THEIR THEIR STIPULATION.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE SUNSET
CONSIDERATION WAS THAT ON THE
TABLE? THAT'S I WASN'T PART OF
THE NEGOTIATION. SO IT TODAY IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT'S COME UP
RIGHT? OKAY. I WASN'T PART OF
THE NEGOTIATION EITHER. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS, BUT I
HAVEN'T HEARD IT FROM EITHER
PARTY THAT THAT WAS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. SO OKAY. TO BE
CLEAR, I KNOW WE'RE ON THE
FLOOR, BUT I'M NOT I DON'T WANT
TO RUSH ANY OF THE SENATORS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE,
SENATORS SHOULD ASK ANY QUESTION
THEY WISH, MAKE ANY COMMENT THEY
WISH, AND THEN ASK WHOMEVER THEY
WISH TO RESPOND TO THAT. THAT
QUESTION. THAT'S THAT'S
PERFECTLY FINE, JUST AS WE DO IN
OTHER HEARINGS. SO. ALL RIGHT,
NEXT IS SENATOR LAIRD. I HAVE A
BRIEF COMMENT AND A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR, BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING AS EVERYBODY ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAS, WITH THE FACT
THAT THIS IS COMING ON MONDAY OF
THE LAST WEEK. AND NORMALLY WE
WOULD HAVE A CHANCE TO WORK ON
THIS. AND I THINK IT IS A GOOD
BILL IN THE FRAMEWORK AND IT
GETS TO A BETTER PLACE. AND I
HAVE SORT OF CONCLUDED DURING
THIS DEBATE THAT IF WE WERE TO
ADOPT THIS BILL AND THEN HAVE
STILL NEXT YEAR NEGOTIATIONS ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
STILL AT ISSUE, IT ACTUALLY SETS
THE FRAMEWORK FOR THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS IN THE RIGHT WAY,
BECAUSE IT SORT OF SETS THIS UP
AS THE STARTING GATE TO DO IT,
BECAUSE IF WE WERE TO JUST KICK
THIS BILL OVER TO NEXT YEAR, IN
MANY WAYS IT WOULD BE STARTING
ALL OVER AND IN MANY WAYS, SOME
OF THE CONCESSIONS THAT EACH
SIDE MADE WOULD NOT BE MADE
AGAIN OR WOULD NOT BE ENSHRINED
INTO LAW. SO I'M INCLINED TO
VOTE TO MOVE TO THE BILL. BUT
THAT LEADS TO THE QUESTION WHICH
IS OF THE AUTHOR? ARE YOU
WILLING TO WORK WITH ALL THE
PARTIES IN THE NEXT YEAR TO
ADDRESS WHAT ARE PERCEIVED TO BE
ANY REMAINING ISSUES? YES
ABSOLUTELY. AND, SENATOR, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS MY EIGHTH YEAR
HERE. I DON'T THINK YOU'VE SEEN
ME DO SOMETHING OF THIS NATURE
BEFORE. AND THE REASON WHY IS,
WHAT DO YOU MEAN, INVOLVED IN A
REALLY CONTROVERSIAL. WELL, NO,
NO, NO, THAT I DO ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE I DO ALL THE TIME IN
TERMS OF COMING TO LISTEN TO ALL
THOSE HEARINGS IN THE LAST WEEK
OR TWO, THIS WAS, YOU KNOW, IT
WAS PREDICATED BY THE, YOU KNOW,
HOW THE NEGOTIATIONS WENT AND
WHEN THEY ULTIMATELY COMPLETED.
BUT ABSOLUTELY, I THINK MYSELF
AND CHAIR UMBERG ARE TWO FOLKS
THAT HAVE NO PROBLEM CONTINUING
TO EXAMINE THE WORK THAT WE DO.
I KNOW ALL THE PARTIES HAVE
INDICATED THE SAME. IN FACT, THE
AMENDMENT WE TOOK THIS MORNING
WAS AN AMENDMENT THAT OUR
GENTLEMAN THAT'S BEEN EXPRESSING
SOME CONCERNS BROUGHT TO US LAST
WEEK, AND WE INSERTED THAT
TODAY. AND SO ANY SUGGESTION
THAT WE'RE NOT WILLING TO BE
FLEXIBLE IN LISTENING TO ALL
SIDES AND PARTIES, EVEN THOSE
THAT CONTINUE TO OBJECT TO THE
LEGISLATION WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS, THAT'S FINE. THAT'S
THEIR PREROGATIVE. IT DOESN'T
MEAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO TRY TO
MAKE IT BETTER. THE SUGGESTION
WAS A GOOD ONE. WE TOOK IT UP
TODAY. THE MANUFACTURERS AGREED
WITH IT. AND SO WE BELIEVE
THAT'S GOING TO BE NÓ. YOU'RE AN
ATTORNEY, I AM THE ANSWER WAS
YES. RIGHT. BUT YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER, I WAS YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER I WAS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. WE HAD TO SOMETIMES,
YOU KNOW, FIND WE HAD WE HAVE
DRAMATICS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD,
SENATOR YELLOW AND SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR.
I'M WITH MY FELLOW FRESHMAN AND
LONGTIME FRIEND, SENATOR ASHBY.
I FEEL JAMMED, AND I KIND OF
DON'T LIKE THAT, NOW, AS A CAR
DEALER, I AM NOT INVOLVED IN
LEMON LAW CASES, BUT I AM AN
OBSERVER. ALTHOUGH NOT TO THE
PROCESS. SO I DON'T SEE ALL THAT
LABORIOUS STUFF GOING ON IN THE
BACKGROUND. BUT AGAIN, I'M NOT
DIRECTLY INVOLVED, SO IT'S NOT
AN ISSUE THAT I HAVE TO ABSTAIN,
AND I'M NOT GOING TO ABSTAIN. I
AM, HOWEVER, NOT GOING TO VOTE.
AND THE REASON IS THAT, NUMBER
ONE BEING JAMMED, I BRIEFLY
SPOKE WITH MR. BOEHLERT EARLIER
TO LET HIM KNOW WHERE I WAS, I
AM FEELING KIND OF JAMMED, AND I
DON'T FEEL NOW. I'M NOT AN
ATTORNEY, ALTHOUGH I PLAY ONE.
EVERY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, BUT
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME ASSESSING
THIS AS A PERMANENT, EFFECTIVE
REFORM. THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND
SENATOR LAIRD'S POINT COULD BE
ONE WELL TAKEN, BUT WE'RE JUST
TAKING THE WORD OF THE AUTHOR
THAT HE'S GOING TO WORK
DILIGENTLY TO BRING IN THE
FEELINGS AND IDEAS OF THOSE THAT
ARE OPPOSED, AND MAYBE, MAYBE
NOT, BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
INVOLVED IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
THE REALLY INTERESTING THING
ABOUT THIS, WHICH IS I FIND KIND
OF UNIQUE, IS THAT WE HAVE
CONSUMER INTERESTS THAT ARE IN
FAVOR AND WE HAVE CONSUMER
INTERESTS THAT ARE OPPOSED. WE
HAVE MANUFACTURERS THAT ARE IN
FAVOR, AND WE HAVE MANUFACTURERS
THAT ARE OPPOSED. WE DON'T OFTEN
SEE COMMON ENTITIES AND PEOPLE
ON BOTH SIDES OF AN ISSUE.
HOWEVER, I DID NOTICE, I THINK,
SENATOR ALLEN, FOR HIS QUESTION,
THAT THERE IS ENOUGH, AGREEMENT
AS TO CERTAIN POSITIVE ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL THAT THE OPPOSITION
COULD AGREE TO AND PERHAPS A
NEGOTIATION INVOLVING ALL
RELEVANT PARTIES CAN WORK TOWARD
A BETTER SOLUTION. AND THE LEMON
LAW, AS IT EXISTS, HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR OVER 50 YEARS. I THINK
THERE'S A REASONABLE CONTENTION
THAT PERHAPS IT IS TIME TO TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT IT, BUT I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE PASSING THIS BILL
WITH JUST THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE OPPOSITION THAT WASN'T
INVOLVED BEFORE IS ALL OF A
SUDDEN GOING TO BE INVOLVED. AND
PERHAPS THE BILL AMENDED. SO, I,
I'M NOT GOING TO VOTE. NO, BUT I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL, SO I
WILL BE ABSTAINING AGAIN, NOT
BECAUSE I'M CONFLICTED, BUT
BECAUSE I TRULY AM NOT GOING TO
VOTE ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE REASONS I
STATED. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US TO BE
ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS AND TO
SPEAK, COULD I ASK THE
OPPOSITION, HOW WHEN WAS IT THAT
YOU SAW THE DOCUMENT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TODAY? THE THANK YOU,
SENATOR, THE BILL LANGUAGE CAME
OUT LAST TUESDAY EVENING AND
SOME OF US WERE AWARE OF THE
FRAMEWORK AGREEMENT, ABOUT A
WEEK BEFORE THAT. BUT GM
ACCEPTED, AT LEAST FROM OUR
OPPOSITION COALITION, ZERO
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. YEAH. AND
WE FOUND OUT WHEN IT WAS IN
PRINT WE DIDN'T SEE ANY LANGUAGE
BEFORE THEN. RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELL, I LET ME JUST
SAY THAT, THIS IS ONE OF THE
HARDER BILLS, I THINK THAT THAT
WE'VE SEEN MOSTLY BECAUSE WE ALL
PRETTY MUCH SAW IT LATE, BUT IT
IS DEFINITELY AN AREA WHERE,
THERE IS GREAT CONSTERNATION AND
REAL CONCERN, WE HAVE A LEGAL
SYSTEM THAT IS DOESN'T REALLY
FUNCTION EFFICIENTLY RIGHT NOW,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
JUDGES, FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF
REASONS AND ANYTHING THAT CLOGS
UP THE COURT SYSTEM IS REALLY, A
MEANS THAT THEIR ACCESS TO
JUSTICE JUST ISN'T THERE. I WANT
TO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT,
IT'S A GOOD FRAMEWORK, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN BETTER TO HAVE IT DONE
EARLIER SO THAT WE COULD ALL
TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND MAKE MAKE
SOME SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF, OF
CHANGE. I THERE'S NO QUESTION IN
MY MIND IT NEEDS MORE WORK AND
IT NEEDS A SUNSET SO THAT WE CAN
COME BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT
WHETHER IT'S WORKING AND WHETHER
THERE'S A SUNSET STARTS PUTTING
A TIMELINE. THE QUESTION BECAME,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, ARE YOU
COMMITTED TO, YOU KNOW, WORKING
SOME MORE ON THIS AND, AND
WORKING OUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
WORKED OUT. AND YOU SAID, YES, I
BELIEVE YOU, BUT A SUNSET REALLY
CREATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
IT DONE AND TO DO IT EARLY
ENOUGH. SO, I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY, BUT I DO THINK THAT WE
NEED TO, SO AND LET ME SAY WHY,
I TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AND I
THINK THE EARLIER IT IS THAT
THERE IS NOTICE THAT THERE'S A
FRAMEWORK FOR FROM WHICH TO
ADVISE THE MANUFACTURERS THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM AND THAT,
THAT, THAT IT HAS TO BE FIXED,
IS A GOOD THING. AND WHAT I SEE
OUT OF THE, OUT OF THE LANGUAGE
IS, IS IT IT STARTS A, IT STARTS
A CLOCK, BUT IT'S A CLOCK THAT
BENEFITS THE CONSUMER, AS WELL
AS A CLOCK THAT ADVISES THE
MANUFACTURER AND THE, THE DEALER
AS WELL. THE DEALERS DON'T WANT
TO BE STUCK IN THE MIDDLE OF
THESE SITUATIONS. THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE. AND MANY TIMES THEY
DO, BECAUSE THE, THE LEMON CAR
KEEPS GETTING TAKEN INTO THE
DEALERSHIP AND OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON WHEN
IT IT PROBABLY SHOULD BE HANDLED
BY THE MANUFACTURER. SO I THINK
THIS IS, THIS IS NOT AN EASY
AREA OF THE LAW TO DEAL WITH.
AND AND, AND I THANK YOU FOR,
FOR TAKING THIS ON, DURING THIS
LAST TIME, BUT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
JUST A FEW THINGS. FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU, SENATOR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRA, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, AND I COMMIT WITH YOU
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT AND COMPLEX ISSUE. I
WANT TO NOTE, SENATOR ROTH
MENTIONING THAT THIS THE SONG
BEVERLEY ACT IS 50 YEARS OLD,
WHICH MAKES ME FEEL A LITTLE OLD
BECAUSE I SERVED WITH BOB
BEVERLEY, WHO, BY THE WAY, WAS A
REPUBLICAN SENATOR, HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE, AS WELL AS SALLY
TANNER WAY BACK IN THE DAY, A
COUPLE OF THINGS HERE IS THAT
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL,
ALTHOUGH I DIDN'T NEGOTIATE IT,
IS FAMILIAR BECAUSE A LOT OF IT
COMES FROM WHAT WE HAD DONE TO
TAKE FEDERAL RULE 26, WHICH
REQUIRES EARLY DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION, WITNESSES,
DOCUMENTS AND THE LIKE TO
EXPEDITE LITIGATION. AND IT IS
INCORPORATED INTO THIS BILL. THE
TERM RELEVANT IS NOW BEING
DEFINED AS WE SPEAK BY THE
VARIOUS COURTS, BECAUSE THAT IS
EXISTING LAW AS OF JANUARY 1ST,
2024, AND CERTAINLY DOCUMENTS IN
MY MIND. AND IF IT'S NOT CLEAR,
WE'LL MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE DELIVERED
BETWEEN THE DEALER AND THE
MANUFACTURER ARE CLEARLY
RELEVANT DOCUMENTS. THE
AFFIRMATIVE OBLIGATION STILL
EXISTS ON THE PART OF THE
MANUFACTURER. THERE IS NO SHIFT
SO FAR AS I READ THE BILL. AND
TO MAKE IT CLEAR, AND I'LL ASK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAHLER, I THINK
HE AGREES WITH ME. THERE'S NO
SHIFT IN TERMS OF THE BURDEN.
THE MANUFACTURER STILL HAS THE
BURDEN OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
REMEDIES ARE PROVIDED TO THE
CONSUMER. THE, THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE, I RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE ALL HAVE
BECAUSE THIS IS THRUST UPON US
THE LAST WEEK THAT LITERALLY THE
BUSIEST WEEK OF A TWO YEAR
SESSION, BUT IT IS HERE. AND THE
QUESTION NOW IS WHETHER WE
CREATE THIS FRAMEWORK TO MOVE
FORWARD, SUBJECT AS IT IS, TO
MODIFICATION IN THE YEARS HENCE.
SO WITH THAT, I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION. YES. I JUST I JUST
WANT TO SAY I'M GOING TO LAY OFF
OF THE BILL TODAY, AND I JUST
NEED YOU TO UNDERSTAND WHY HAD
THERE BEEN A SUNSET, I PROBABLY
COULD HAVE GOTTEN THERE, BUT I
JUST AND I KNOW THERE'S STILL
TIME ON THE CLOCK. AND THE
REASON I'M TAKING THE MOMENT TO
CHIME IN WHILE WE ALL REALLY
WANT TO GET TO THE FLOOR, IS
THAT THERE'S STILL TIME ON THE
CLOCK FOR YOU TO MAKE THAT
CHANGE. AND PERHAPS I COULD
RECONSIDER ON THE FLOOR, AND I
THINK IT WOULD BE MEANINGFUL TO
MANY OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT IN
THIS ROOM AND WON'T HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF THIS CONVERSATION.
WELL, CAN WE ASK IF HE'S WILLING
TO ACCEPT A SUNSET? YEAH IF IT'S
THE WILL OF THIS COMMITTEE, TO
ASK FOR A SUNSET, I'M PERFECTLY
FINE WITH IT. I BELIEVE THE
PARTIES ARE OKAY, BUT I WOULD
WANT THEM TO SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES. BUT I THINK FIVE
YEAR SUNSET WAS SOMETHING THAT
WAS SUGGESTED. BUT I ALSO WANT
TO ASK MY JOINT AUTHOR AS WELL.
SO I, YOU KNOW, I'M KIND OF I'M
OKAY WITH. BUT IT'S NOT JUST ME.
I THINK IT'S FOR A COUPLE OF US.
LET ME INTERRUPT FOR JUST A
SECOND. HERE'S THE CHALLENGE
WITH THE SUNSET. AND IF IT'S IF
IT'S THE WILL OF THE AUTHOR,
THEN I'M WILLING TO ACCEDE TO
THE WILL OF THE AUTHOR AS A
JOINT AUTHOR, TO INCORPORATE A
SUNSET. BUT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE A SUNSET IN, IN A BILL
CONCERNING CIVIL PROCEDURE, THEN
IT INVITES THE PARTIES WHO DON'T
LIKE THAT PROCEDURE TO BASICALLY
DELAY AS LONG AS THEY POSSIBLY
CAN SO THEY CAN AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF THE FORMER PROCEDURE. SO TO
THE EXTENT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SUNSET, I WOULD SUGGEST IT BE
LONG ENOUGH THAT WE DON'T INVITE
GAMESMANSHIP HERE IN THE FILING
OF CLAIMS. SO I AGREE, SENATOR
BARRASSO, MY CONCERN WITH THE
SUNSET IS WE JUST HAD A
CONVERSATION BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT FIXING THIS AND MAYBE AS
EARLY AS NEXT YEAR, FIXING AND
WORKING TOGETHER. LET'S SEE WHAT
WHAT MAKES SENSE, WHAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE BECAUSE OF THE TIME
CRUNCH THAT WE'RE IN. MY CONCERN
IS YOU PUT A SUNSET, THEN YOU'RE
BASICALLY SAYING, LET'S HOLD
OFF. I'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
BEFORE. LET'S HOLD OFF. LET'S
NOT DO ANYTHING TO FIX IT,
BECAUSE THERE'S A SUNSET HERE ON
WHICH ALL OF US SHOULD WORK OFF
OF AND RESPECT THE SUNSET, AND
NOT REALLY DO MUCH UNTIL THE
SUNSET GIVES. YOU KNOW, THAT
TIME HAS PASSED. SO I'M, I'M
VERY CONCERNED PRIMARILY BECAUSE
WE HAVE AS MUCH OF A COMMITMENT
HERE AS YOU COULD POSSIBLY GET
TO FIX IT, WHATEVER THAT MAY
MEAN. ALL RIGHT. SO, YES,
SENATOR WAHAB, SO SORRY, TO ADD
TO THIS WONDERFUL CONVERSATION,
WHAT ABOUT INSTEAD OF A SUNSET,
A ONE YEAR DELAY OF
IMPLEMENTATION TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYTHING IS UP TO PAR BY NEXT
YEAR? I WOULD PROBABLY BE. I
WOULD FIND THAT PROBABLY MORE
PROBLEMATIC THAN THAN A SUNSET,
ONLY BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM IS
CURRENTLY BROKEN AND THAT ONCE
IT'S IMPLEMENTED, I THINK WE'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHAT
SEE IF SOME OF THE HORROR
STORIES THAT ARE BEING, YOU
KNOW, COME TO FRUITION OR NOT.
AND I THINK TWO OBSERVATIONS IN
TERMS OF AT LEAST MY OBSERVATION
OF HOW CIVIL LITIGANTS PROCEED.
IF THERE'S A SUNSET, LET'S SAY
THERE'S A ONE YEAR SUNSET THAT
YOU WILL SEE LOTS OF, LITIGATION
PRACTICE BY THOSE WHO WISH NOT
TO BE BOUND BY THE LAW TO DELAY
THINGS. IF THERE'S A DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION, YOU WILL SEE AN
ACCELERATION BY THOSE WHO WISH
TO USE AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
CURRENT LAW. SO IT I THINK IT
EITHER HAS HAS IMPACTS ON THE
COURTS AND WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE VARIOUS
REPRESENTATIVES. YES. SENATOR
ROTH, LET ME LET ME JUST MAKE AN
OBSERVATION. I MEAN, THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF CONVERSATION HERE.
WHILE I WILL NOT BE HERE NEXT
YEAR, THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON THE DAIS WHO WILL WHO ARE
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT
CERTAIN PORTIONS OF THIS BILL,
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE'VE GOT A BUNCH OF
MANUFACTURERS ON ONE SIDE AND
SOME ON THE OTHER. AND FRANKLY,
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT THE NATURE OF THAT
OPPOSITION REALLY IS. WE HAVE
HEARD WHAT THE CONCURRENCE IS.
IF YOU DON'T START TO WORK ON
THIS THING, THEN I SUSPECT ONE
OF THESE FOLKS WHO WILL BE HERE
NEXT YEAR AFTER JANUARY IN A NEW
SESSION, WILL OFFER A BILL TO
FIX WHAT WE'VE JUST BEEN TALKING
ABOUT HERE. AND SO I'M NOT SURE
WE NEED TO WORRY ABOUT ONE YEAR
DELAYS OR SUNSETS AT THIS POINT,
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WILL
OPERATIONALLY HAPPEN IS THERE
WILL BE A BILL. SO IT'S SO HARD.
WELL, I, I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT. I
WILL OFFER MY OPINION ON WHETHER
YOU CAN DO AN AMENDMENT FROM THE
DAIS AT THE LAST FOUR DAYS OF
SESSION, BUT I WON'T. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. I'M SORRY, I ALREADY
MADE A MOTION. YES, THAT'S
RIGHT, SENATOR CHÁVEZ MADE A
MOTION ALL RIGHT, MOTION HAS
BEEN MADE. I'M SORRY. ARE WE
ADDING TO SUNSET? THE. THE
MOTION WAS TO MOVE THE BILL AS
WRITTEN. YEAH. THE MOTION IS AS
WRITTEN. I THINK, GIVEN THE
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION, INCLUDING
FROM THE CHAIR, IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACT OF A SUNSET, I'LL PROCEED
AS WRITTEN AS THE MOTION STATES.
ALL RIGHT, WE'D LIKE TO CLOSE. I
APPRECIATE LOOK, I THIS IS NOT
HOW I WOULD WANT TO DO IT
EITHER. OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS, BUT I'M NOT GOING
ANYWHERE. HOPEFULLY FOR A LITTLE
WHILE. SOME OF YOU ARE GOING TO
BE HERE HOPEFULLY A LOT LONGER
THAN THAT. AND I THINK, AS
INDICATED BY SENATOR ROTH,
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST FOR A
REASON. AND I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US ARE GOING TO ALLOW SOMETHING
TO CONTINUE IF IT'S BAD FOR
CONSUMERS. I THINK THIS WILL BE
GOOD FOR CONSUMERS, AND I THINK
TIME WILL BE ABLE TO TELL THAT.
AND AS INDICATED BY AMENDMENTS
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN IN A
RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
FROM OPPOSITION, I HOPE THAT
INDICATES THAT, YES, I'M MORE
THAN WILLING TO TAKE MORE
FEEDBACK AND CONVENE MEETINGS
WITH WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS AB
1755. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
UMBERG A UMBERG I WILK I WILK I
ALLEN I ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY NO.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I GRASSO
DURAZO I LAIRD. LAIRD I NIETO.
ROTH I ROTH I STERN I STERN I
WAHAB WAHHAB I. 9 TO 1 NINE ONE
BILL PASSES. THANK YOU ALL. OKAY
THAT WAS FUN. WE ARE ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.